okay 10: a.m. we're going to get going
um representative bone would you like to
lead us in the
pledge
okay um welcome all back I hope you all
had a good week a good break I should
say hope you had a good first of the
nation primary to all those of you who
participated um going to open up the um
this meeting of the house election law
committee we're going to start off with
the public hearing for hb1 1446 FN local
relative to eliminating the costs for
electronic copies of the checklist and
representative Claudine Burnham is
recognize to introduce the
Bill thank you Mr chairman and thank you
committee um so yes this um HB
1446 is um pretty simple uh there's a
fee that's attached to the requests of a
voter's checklist in town and at the
Secretary of State's office of $25 so
this um Bill reduces that electronic
copies this would just be for electronic
copies of the voters
checklist um from the current cost of
$25 to a zero cost to the request to the
one requesting the copy um I requested a
copy last September it took less than 2
minutes and I had to pay $25 and it came
as a PDF so um it it's kind of seems
silly to charge that amount um to get a
copy of that um there's no extra time
and it's a simple process I understand
that there is a fiscal note um
that the Secretary of State's office
would potentially lose over $180,000 in
Revenue um um but this is public
information and with a very little
effort to send it electronically or by a
um USB
device um is
um makes it easier to for the transfer
and um I think it's fair for those um
who are requesting it to receive it at
no cost I would be comfortable with the
um that Revenue
not being uh collected for that very
reason
um so uh as far as with the towns um I
don't know about the other towns uh loss
and revenue but I'm the only one that's
requested a copy so that wasn't a huge
loss for my town either so with that I
would um ask you to consider to pass
this through and um make it a easier to
get electronic copies will you be taking
questions I can are there questions from
the committee representative wood is
recognized yes thank you for taking my
question um are you do you know how
often the um the voter role or voter
list is is changed is updated
um it I think that as I don't know as
far as uh the state level but in the
towns I would assume um it depends on
when people
are remember if it's um
how often it is for the the actual copy
to be presented but I know in my town if
there are changes they'll updated every
few months especially right before
elections as the newest copy yeah was a
little bit of a trick question because
I've been having trouble finding that
out it cost me $76 to get the voter
roles for Chester and Pittsville those
are the two towns that I represent and
uh you know and I end up getting the
list this probably more often than I
need to because I really don't know and
it's the same thing I get a uh
electronic copy of it so I think maybe
uh somebody else can ask that answer
that question but I think in this day
and age it would be really nice if 3:00
in the morning I could pull that down
offline but that's just my two cents so
I know I got nothing else to do thank
you representative Howard's
recognized thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question uh so have
you spoken to the clerk's Association or
any of your town clerks uh about this
bill and in the drafting process um I
have talked to um the Town Clerk and uh
he was a bit surprised that there's a
fee for the electronic version because
really it's it doesn't take much
especially if it's in a PDF but and you
can also transfer to an Excel
spreadsheet it's um it's not cumbersome
it doesn't take much time
so
yep
president
Bay thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um I I did go to my
town clerk last September also to get
the I paid the $25 I brought my new um
uh USB thumb drive um is the $25 fee is
that causing any
hardship uh to anyone who would need it
or would want it and what kind of hard
they give me a description of what type
of hardship that's causing um I I don't
believe there's a hardship but at the
same time it should be public access
information um and
um where it's not costing the town very
much to do that in an electronic form
they're not taking time to print out or
get paper things like that um and so I I
just I just think it's a kind of a uh
senseless fee when it could just be done
quickly representative
Wood please turn your mic on represent
sorry um do you know if other states um
charge in are there any other states
that don't charge I guess that's what I
wanted to ask for yes good question
thank you um yes so apparently there is
I know that somebody will be speaking on
that um the details but uh some states
do charge a lot more and some states
don't charge anything
so okay thank you but they'll I'm sure
you'll get more details
soon further
questions representive
Howard so uh why did you make the
decision to have the town Supply the
external storage uh rather than allow
people to bring their own hard drives in
uh yeah good question yes so when we
were um drafting that that came up um as
more of a safety feature um so certainly
I believe if you can bring a brand new
one but
uh um it would I I think it just gives a
little bit more security for the town
level um and the state level to provide
that
followup uh do you have an estimated
cost that it could be per town I mean
just across the
state for the USBs yes um well I just
paid $7.99 I think for a pretty good
quality one so if you buy them in bulk
I'm sure it could be a lot less all
right thank
you awesome any further questions all
right thing done thank you uh
representative weie you're up
next
can you turn on your microphone oh there
we go thank you thank you Mr chair thank
you committee members um what I want to
uh as a co-sponsor of the bill I want to
just uh run through a few facts related
to the checklist to uh touch on the
imperative nature of having access to
this
information in the 2020 general election
the voter uh role lists were calculated
to have a total of 1 million 11
19,23 to voters in 2021 the 10-year
voter list Purge or voter role list
verification required under RSA
654 col 39 had a net removal of
approximately 21% of the state's voter
role list reducing the list down to a
calculated total of
279 voter or a difference in uh over a
quarter of a million votes actually to
239 uh
1,953 voters so if you compare so that's
roughly a 21% drop if you compare the
change in
population during that same period of
time New Hampshire had approximately a
5.1%
growth um so if the number of reduced
voters on the checklist accounts for
transfers in and out of New Hampshire as
well as
deaths um you have you know
approximately uh 16% unaccounted for now
some of that might be voters voting for
the first time other factors like that
but it's a huge change in the number of
people on the checklist which is
indicative of the fact that all
checklists are perhaps not being
properly maintained therefore I think
it's incumbent upon candid Cates and
other concerned voter interest groups to
be able to have access to this
information so that they may verify it
on a local or wider level I would also
add that based upon a voter Integrity
group that provided affidavits for
voters who were no longer in their
residence and voting so they were
identified as voters then it was
verified whether or not that they were
uh domiciled or residing in their listed
address and and there were over 15,000
affidavits submitted
to the attorney general pointing out
that these voters were not had voted in
the 2020 election but were not domiciled
or in their residence as identified at
the time of the voting so um this is
something that needs to be uh able to be
verified at the local level uh there are
other bills coming up in the future so
you'll probably hear these numbers a few
times more from me um I like to think of
it as people like to say our elections
and say are safe and secure I think the
safest and most secure thing uh in the
2020 election apparently was the
checklist because they were not altered
at all um so I think it is uh you know
just to kind of put a bow on the ri uh
ribbon and Bo on the package here it is
important that the cost be minimal for
electronic copies so that candidates can
have access and other interested groups
can have access to make sure that our
checklists have the Integrity needed now
this is not casting aspersions on any
local supervisors of the checklist I am
sure that they are doing the best that
they can um but sometimes uh voters who
have that interest or candidates who
have that interest can invest additional
time resources that perhaps are not
provided or available to the supervisors
of the checklist so that's all I have to
say on that matter questions from the
committee representative Bay thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question you alluded to a minimal fee uh
which is it seems to be inconsistent
with eliminating the cost so when you're
when you refer to a minimal fee what fee
would that be what's the minimal fee
so the the minimal fee might be for
example if they wanted to send it
instead of emails put it on a thumb
drive so I think the value mentioned was
$799 before for a secure transfer of
electronic
information followup followup so um the
minimal fee will just be for the
physical uh vehicle for transferring
that data yes the data should already
exist so therefore the transfer of the
electronic information really should be
no cost at all if in fact Hardware is
involved if they choose instead of
emailing the information to transfer it
through a thumb drive for flash drive
then there would be some minimal fee
associated with that or minimal cost
associated with that I think um in fact
in my own town uh when someone recently
requested electronic information they
actually asked that they provide a
secure thumb drive that had not been
opened so the package was intact from
one of the local stores providing that
sort of thing so the the town was happy
to take that unopen package um and then
use the thumb drive in that package so
in fact if if such an arrangement were
made with the town then the town would
have absolutely no expenditure other
than pressing the appropriate buttons to
affect the exchange of electronic
information thank
you further
questions okay um Ron B want to follow
up so um do you think that that the cost
of labor for actually putting together
that uh
database and extracting uh the
information that you need is uh
zero
at the local level or at the secretary
of state level wherever you think that
work is getting done because it's like
there there's a fee it's like even if if
I'm uh maintaining a database you ask me
for something I push the button and say
here it is the the the the pushing the
button and the two seconds that it took
or I don't know two minutes is is
probably just the face of it but there
is
work that cost labor that's involved in
making sure that when you come to me it
only takes me two seconds so if you're
talking about the labor associated with
creating the checklist of course that
would be the responsibility of the
supervisors of the checklist which is a
usually an elected position most towns
and City
Wards further
questions hearing none Thank You
represenative Weary um representative
pelli you are up
next
since you're the first person not say
welcome to election law thank you good
morning thank you for hearing my
testimony my name is Susan
representative Susan pelli I represent
District 19 in Rockingham Hampton Falls
and Kensington and we're two small
towns I support this bill to eliminate
the cost for an electronic copy of a
checklist that is in a sortable
format communicating with our voters is
an integral part of our democracy and it
is a pivotal point for our right of free
speech I believe having access to this
data will encourage civic participation
which is De desperately needed in our
small
towns as you know as rep candidates we
don't have access access to unlimited
funds so charging for data that's
already available can be detrimental to
those that are wishing to seek office at
a local level or to support a particular
issue in
town our rep candidates really need to
have access to this data but think about
the participation that we want from our
small and large towns we have many
different offices
and um causes that would benefit from
this type of data so if you are running
for your planning board or your school
board or if you have a committee that
has a particular issue and you want to
communicate with your constituents this
data is absolutely
invaluable I spoke to my town clerk they
are fully in support of providing this
data they already
have it from the secretary of state so
there is no onerous labor involved
whatsoever I think it's very important
to have this bill pass on a
bipartisan way so that we can show in
New Hampshire we support our elected
officials
our constituents that have U reasons to
communicate with our voters and our
voters to respect them so that we could
make sure that we're communicating
effectively so the the fee could prevent
certain citizens our citizen
legislature from accessing this data
appropriately and that fee could deter
their
participation as far as the external
drive goes I'm sure everyone knows what
they look like I found on Amazon you
could purchase 10 of these in a 10pack
for the cost of about
$2 and as already stated it would be
very coste effective for someone to
bring in their own thumb drive in a
package that's unopened to make sure
that we maintain Security on our systems
so in conclusion I am fully in support
of this bipartisan effort to be able ble
to provide data to our elected officials
to our local level Grassroots organizers
to towns people that have a particular
interest in an issue and be able to
fully communicate with our constituents
without the barrier of a FEI thank Youk
you qu we be taking questions sure
representative
Hamlet thank you um Mr chair thank you
for taking my question so is the
checklist that's created by the
supervisors of the checklist of the town
is that in a sortable format yes and
it's also available from the Secretary
of State in that sortable format so I'm
sure we're all interest um familiar with
you know workbook type software Excel
Etc okay and it's very helpful to be
able to have that format so you can sort
and especially how many here have gone
door knocking so especially you know we
here in New Hampshire we have the we are
so unique that we communicate directly
with our voters and being able to have
that in a sortable format so you can
look and say okay um on Main Street
today who who would I like to talk to on
Main Street today as opposed to a format
that does not lend itself to sorting and
it becomes very onerous especially in
larger communities okay thank you thank
you further questions seeing none thank
you um next up secretary of state
scanland Secretary scanland well done
last Tuesday last Tuesday right well
done well done give him a quick Round of
Applause thank you and your
team well thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee I'm David scanland
Secretary of State and uh I'm not here
to take a position uh on this bill
because this is clearly uh in the domain
of the legislature to decide how much uh
should be charged for uh checklists from
the voter
database I will say that
historically uh there has been a charge
for these lists um the database has
existed since probably around
2006 prior to that checklists were
passed out in paper form and I believe
the charge was
$25 per checklist uh at that time to do
that uh and that price structure has
carried forward today again as a matter
of policy uh of the state
legislature the supervisors of the
checklist in every town are the ones
that are responsible for for maintaining
the list uh they are the only
individuals the only the only officials
election officials that are authorized
authorized to put names on the list and
remove names from the list and they're
required to meet by Statute at certain
times of the year usually immediately
preceding uh elections or town
meetings uh and to make adjustments uh
to provide for new registrations after
an election is over so the supervisors
do all the all the grunt work uh in
terms of M maintaining that list they
maintain the list in the Statewide voter
registration database and the database
itself is maintained and administered uh
from the technical standpoint by the
state of New Hampshire uh by individuals
in my office at the secretary of
state so uh as a result of that uh
checklists can be provided in electronic
format um and
uh and the statute requires that there's
a fee uh that is associate associated
with
that if it is the policy of the
legislature to eliminate the fee then I
think there are certain additional
policy uh decisions that also have to be
made uh number one is that this language
uh in the proposed
legislation requires that the checklist
be made available by
email and I would like to say that I
don't think the technology currently
exists to allow that to happen in every
instance uh the file is huge and and I
know that if somebody was acquiring a
Statewide list it simply we simply could
not send it by email so my suggestion is
that that be a May and not a shall um
some of the small towns might be able to
transfer that data by email but um I
think for the most part it would be more
practical to deliver it on a thumb drive
uh which you have
seen as was mentioned I know that if
somebody's acquiring the list from the
state and I think this is true in most
towns we require that we provide the
media that that the information goes on
because we don't want to insert a a form
of media that we have no idea where it's
been uh and what might be on it that
could uh cause security issues with our
uh database
system and then the last concern uh well
um the money that is collected uh
through the sale of those lists uh and
even the ones at the state level go back
to the cities and towns to help them
cover the costs of maintaining the list
they help pay for the time that uh the
that the supervisor spend uh maintaining
that list and as you saw on the fiscal
note there's roughly
$171,000 a year that gets back to the
get that gets sent back to the cities
and towns uh for that purpose again
that's a policy decision of the
legislature to make the concern that I
would have that if that fee was
eliminated and there would be a
natural uh restraint that would be
removed from the number of requests for
checklists that would be made uh I think
that that if if the checklist is
basically free it's going to
dramatically increase the number of
these that gets sent out and not only
that the
checklist at at the Statewide level
changes every single day and I could
Envision situations where the same
individual would be requesting that list
once a week uh because there's no cost
uh to do that and that would uh you know
that would cause uh probably a
requirement for some additional staff
just to help manage that uh uh that
scenario so uh that's really all that I
have to offer but I would be happy to
answer any
questions representative wood thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
questions and thank you for answering my
questions every day cost me $76 for Two
Towns we have four elections this year
do I do it four times I that's my
concern and that's the reason why I
think this bill is the other thing you
mentioned is uh you think it would
increase the number so it it seems to
make the bill in my opinion valuable uh
I don't see people collecting databases
for sport and uh I I don't mean to
testify sorry what's your feeling on
that um I I I I think you kind of help
us
in in your uh in what you say well like
I said I'm not taking a position on the
bill one way or the other I'm just
providing okay the facts and and what I
see happening if this version of the
bill were to pass yeah can I follow up
please um well we we go other Members
First where we allow followup
representative
Bay thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um when we request um
data for uh what are the data fields
that are included uh I know what I got
from my town clerk but I don't know like
did they give me all I can ask for I
could have asked for but what are
included when the when data are
released the data fields that are
collected are everything that is in the
public version of the checklist and so
that would be the voter's name their
party affiliation both their mailing
address and their physical address
uh it would
include um a voter history for a
two-year period I believe those are the
those are the key elements but it would
be everything that is on the public
list follow we got other Members First
do other members have a question all
right then we'll go back to
representative
wood I I will refrain from uh um
debating the bill I assume you're going
to be back here uh when we we bring the
bill to the uh committee but I did have
one question on um you provide a lot of
data now and again 2 o'clock in the
morning I'm on there I got every
election result from uh the primary
broken down by you know by uh um um
District by towns um just click a link
and I get all that data why can't oh
would you be for doing a similar thing
with the
database
the the the statutes that are currently
on the books are very clear in the
database what is private and conf
confidential data to each individual
voter and we feel feel very strongly
about
protecting information that should
remain private and confidential the the
public part of the list is uh searchable
I mean you can get it in an access
database format or uh a spreadsheet and
you can manipulate uh those data fields
in whatever you know way you want to
orient them or you know sort them
out the
um because we have so much data that
there are uh you know there are certain
um informative fields that we could
probably Aggregate and you know report
on you know on the basis of percentages
and things like that
that would not provide unique
identifiers but but I think that's a
different I think that's a different
topic thank you represent Bay thank you
Mr
chair um so when you said if its emails
probably be too big so it has to be a
different uh electronic mechanism I'm
imagining uh you're going to have a VPN
site where we can all go and and grab it
are there
any um like I don't know probably
encryption or or or ways so that this
data are uh not something that can be
used in egregious manners um like of I'm
glad you didn't say email but let's say
if if there's emails like oh my God
they're using it for for for spam but
are there certain things that can be
done so that the data are protected for
the
individuals uh who are in the
database okay again we're talking about
the public data that everybody has a
right to see so when we are putting it
on uh Electronic
media uh for the individual that has
requested it there really isn't a need
to uh encrypt
it there is no other reason to be
sharing other information that's in the
database and we don't so uh we really
haven't been in that situation where we
have had to encrypt that data thank you
any further questions hearing none thank
you thank
you uh Mr Grace you're up next with the
New Hampshire Municipal
Association thank you Mr chair n gra for
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
uh we do oppose this bill um really the
secretary outlined our concerns um
realistically our major concern here is
uh the cost and the loss of Revenue to
municipalities which the Secretary of
State's office was able to provide to
the committee
um I do want to note that if it is the
committee's uh interest in passing this
legislation um I would make one
suggestion um which is to adjust that $5
charge for the flash drive to be um in
line with the actual cost of copying
that would uh that would cause
the bill to fall more in line with the
existing rights to no law um it would
reflect what the Supreme Court said in
Taylor versus SAU 55 um back in 2017
where the issue was the cost of a one of
the issues was the cost of a flash drive
which was
$749 we heard testimony today um from
the prime sponsor that the cost is
$7.99 and another individual that was $2
for a 10 pack um by fixing the fee at
$5 that may or may not be enough to
cover the cost um really realistically
if we could just have it at the actual
cost that would be beneficial so that
taxpayers aren't subsidizing these
requests in that manner I'm happy to
take questions questions from the
Committee hearing none thank you thank
you um last up is Katherine lill I I may
be mispronouncing the last name
langel all right well we got you
Katherine
sorry
of raptor if you could hold on to that
we don't want to Dole out that during
the testimony cool I appreciate you guys
thank you well good morning um for the
record my name is Katherine LEL I'm
public policy fellow with open democracy
action I'm a 20-year-old voter in
conquered uh open democracy uh
represents voters from across the state
of New Hampshire all from a variety of
different backgrounds and experiences
and including a variety of town clerks
and supervisors of the checklist um the
proposed bill in its current form would
eliminate oh I'm sorry I we oppose this
bill um the proposed bill in its current
form would eliminate the cost of
obtaining electronic copies of the
checklist however in it keeping with
current local and Municipal laws this
would not eliminate the cost of
accessing this document from towns that
have a fee written into their fee
schedule um we contacted Michelle Stayin
from the Franklin City manager's office
she serves as Franklin's town clerk um
in an effort to gain some perspective on
this bill and its proposed effects she
said we do have this fee in our fee
schedule as a city I believe we would
still charge it because of this under
chapter 160 fees there is a spot that
states quote checklist with a fee of $25
plus 50 per uh 1,000 names in excess of
2,500 um if I'm misunderstanding this
please feel free to correct me uh
secretary scanlin or anyone else um
however I we reached out in an effort to
gain some perspective on this labor
costs for a person's effort are not
unheard of in our economy and keeping
public records updated and responsibly
kept is a task that's often overlooked
and undervalued um it seems only fair
that a task that takes some effort for
an employee of the community to be able
to charge a fee it seems to make sense
for their valuable time um I'm happy to
take any questions um if I'm unable to
answer I'm happy to divert them and get
you an answer back representative
K how much time does it would it
actually take for you to gather these
records to put them on a flash drive to
provide them sure um in speaking with
some of our members um who are who serve
as Town clerks they spend at least an
hour every day um keeping things up
updated in terms of deaths um new voters
Etc which seems like a good portion of
their time out of each shift every
day you followup follow so I'm not
asking about maintenance but I'm asking
about so they're going to have to do
that regardless of somebody's getting a
copy of it or not they have to keep that
updated so how much time would it
actually take to actually provide this
service because this is the service that
we'd be asking them we're not asking
people that are requesting a copy of the
checklist to subsidize the cost of
keeping the checklist up to date because
they already have to do that anyway so
how much time approximately for them to
actually provide that data onto a flash
drive absolutely I as a college student
don't know that exact answer but I can
absolutely find that out for you and
email it to you okay that would be great
thank you absolutely thank you f the
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you so much last up is I'm sorry
did I miss my I was just going to say
thank you okay thank you you no one I
don't think any guys ever said thank you
it so nice um next up is uh Al brand I
always but you your last name Al I'm so
sorry brandano than
brandano U my name is Al brandino I'm
from Kensington New Hampshire and I
speak and supported this bill and the
most troubling thing I've heard today is
the
cost what's the cost of not doing it
let's think about it for a minute where
citizens we pay taxes what is the
purpose of me paying taxes for what
reason do I pay
taxes this is part of a
service this is a service to the
community it's a part of what I pay my
taxes for and I just hope that you will
I mean even in our constitution Part 30
you know part one part
38 we're article 8 we're all supposed to
be responsible for open government and
allow the citizens
how are we going to do that if
everyone's going to continue on this fee
structure it it really is
um I hope you'll support this bill
because the citizens are paying taxes
for what this is part of what we
do will you be taking questions
absolutely are there questions from the
committee okay seeing Oh yes
representative Brenan I apologize thank
you Mr chair are you aware of any
instances where individuals have
requested a checklist and then abused
the checklist by harassing members of
the community based on information that
they were able to obtain on the
checklist I I don't personally but why
should that
be here's the condition people are going
to do things all the time sometimes nice
sometimes not so nice why punish
everybody for people if those those
people are acting out of control or not
within the bounds that shouldn't be the
determination for the rest of us who
don't act like
that further questions seeing none thank
you I have no other people signed up to
speak online there were 46 in support
and 17 signed in opposed with that I am
going to close the public hearing on HB
1446 I'll open the public hearing for HB
1577 representative Brenan I assume
you'll be
introducing well you're the first named
oh I'm sorry representative C I
apologize I got ahead of myself I am
sorry
then
what have you ready representative okay
good morning Mr chairman members of
house election law committee I'm
representative Alvin C of Len serving
eight towns in marac County District 26
today I'm introducing House Bill
1577 an act relative to digital images
of
ballots this bill is intended to provide
an opportunity for New Hampshire
citizens to check for himself the
accuracy of the new digital ballot
tabulating
devices this can be done in a manner
that protects the Integrity of the
original balance and the Machine results
so that any discrepancies found can be
formally investigated with the original
ballots and machine
data the old ACU vote devices have a
history of reporting widely differing
numbers of overvotes that went on for
decades without resolution there were a
couple of steps that could have been
taken to investigate and possibly
minimize the apparent vote problem but
weren't at least we recently got a work
around to bypass the problem by
rejecting vot's uh ballots detected to
have an overvote and have them hand
counted this bill provides an
opportunity for citizens to examine and
possibly identify any idiosyncrasies of
the new digital ballot counting devices
may have so the state can get the
devices corrected or their use
discontinued we need to find and expose
any irregularities these in these
devices early rather than waiting
decades until the devices are near the
end of useful life we deserve extreme
accuracy in accounting of ballots for
our
elections this bill essentially provides
a rather inexpensive way to have some or
all of the new electronic ballot
counting devices audited albeit
unofficially this bill provides a path
for an official audit or investigation
if the results so
weren't for anyone who examines the
digital images and Compares their
observation to the record of how the
machine interpreted each vote on the
ballot the most likely source of
discrepancy would be with poorly marked
ovals by the voter there are
instructions on the ballot saying to
fill in the
oval but a few voters seem to miss that
and only put in a small or lightweight
Mark in the ovals which the machine may
not detect the devices are designed not
to detect smudges or hesitation marks
and count them as
votes an important thing for an observer
to look for is discrepancies in how the
device totals up the votes detected to
see if there are any programming errors
or symptoms of tampering this may be
reported in a formal investigation made
the secretary of state will supervise
this process schedule access for The
Observers and provide for the protection
of the original election data since this
is an
unofficial uh procedure it will need to
wait until after the recount period is
uh to avoid distractions during that
time however the secretary May order an
examination of digital images under his
supervision to be done in conjunction
with a recount or audit if conditions
wen't thank you and I'm happy to answer
any questions you may have questions
from the
committee representative Brennan thank
you and thank you for taking my question
do you have any idea of how much time
this would take a Municipal Employee to
supervise a member of the public wanting
to
view these ballots thank you for the
question as it's as this bill
um says it would be through the
Secretary of State to do this so it
would not be a Municipal issue my
apologies I should have said Secretary
of State's office and an employe of the
state would
be supervising this I don't know and the
secretary is here and I think he'll be
able to better answer that question for
you thank
you and he is up next so uh seeing no
other questions thank you representative
C the one and only secretary
scanland
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee once again I'm David scanland
Secretary of State um here to just
provide information to the committee on
this bill um there there are three
really important tenants in conducting
an election first that voters be able to
cast their votes uh uh privately on a
ballot and that and that they're their
vote remains Anonymous it's secret
number two is that there be a
process uh after the election that
involves recounts and appeals and things
like that that affirm the results and
give the voters confidence that there
was a a good Fair accurate
election and then the third part of that
is that once that is done there is
finality to the election process that
you know the result are what they were
and uh they're behind us and and we move
forward and what representative C has
proposed deals with that middle tenant
of making sure that uh we can have
confidence in uh the election
results and I believe strongly that you
know that process has to be as
transparent uh as we can make it and his
proposal uh is timely maybe a little bit
premature sure uh because we are on the
verge now of going to a new uh uh
generation of ballot counting devices
which use digital scan technology where
the actual image of the ballot can be uh
recorded uh and is available for uh
confirming the results of an election
whether it's through a really rigid or
aggressive uh audit process or whether
we open it up to let citizens have the
opportunity to view those ballots for a
period of time and I think that that is
going to take a little time to determine
how that is going to play out
um from my perspective you know our
focus is on getting these new devices in
place so that uh they replace the the
very rapidly aging ACU vote machines
that are out there
uh I think we need to be looking at what
the audit uh process is going to look
like uh and then and then once we
complete that Focus you know how much
how much broader is the public
opportunity going to be to view the
Ballance so uh I I think that uh
representative C is off to a good start
I think some of the provisions in the
bill need a lot of refinement before
they could be implemented and I'm
certainly happy to work with
representative C and and the committee
on on doing
that be happy to answer any questions
questions yes representative Brennan
thank you do you have any concerns um
about the portion of this bill that
would make ballots public record rather
than um exempt from
91a Yes um there have have on a regular
basis been attempts to exempt the actual
ballots from uh 91a and the position
that I have taken in the past is that uh
keeping the ballots private protects the
secret vote of the
voters um it uh there is a pretty uh
uh uh there is an easy opportunity to re
request recounts uh so that there is an
opportunity to view the ballots uh there
are appeal processes to the to the
recount
process
um because of that I think that you know
there should be a formal organized uh
and
carefully uh um administered opportunity
for voters to see the ballots if they
want to but again at some point there
needs to be finality to the election and
that you know know the results are what
they are and then we move forward and
look at the next
one mman
B thank you chairman I got a question
on page two
line 21 where it
says
or
um yeah what is the word I'm talking
about uh handwriting shall be exempt
from RSA 91a should be public record
would that then really do away with that
it's a secret ballot if handwriting can
be anal analyzed for a mailin ballot
well it could I I have seen and this
doesn't happen often but I have seen
where voters sign their ballot you know
they feel strongly about their vote um
and the um
there are ways um which I think of the
best way to say this prior to the early
1890s vote buying was a real problem in
this country
and and the secret ballot solved that
problem it it just eliminated it on the
spot to the extent that you allow
ballots to be viewed after the election
you create an opportunity for that uh
type of voter fraud to resurface and it
could be as simple as saying you know I
will pay you
$50 if you vote for this person for
president and the way I know it's going
to be your ballot is if on the you know
the the the last race on the ballot you
write in Daniel
Webster
um so you know there are potential fraud
opportunities that go along with making
ballots public as well
says to that point do we allow people to
take pictures of ballots during
recounts
uh yes I don't think there's anything to
prevent that from happening thank
you all right oh representative BR with
a followup please thank you so am I
understanding your testimony correctly
that the
three quick the three points that you
were making earlier this bill
essentially violates all three of those
points no no I think that what what
representative C is proposing here
is an opportunity for giving the public
greater confidence in the election
process by being more
transparent I I think that you know we
have a a generous ability to request
recounts where every ballot is viewed
everybody that's observing can see how
those ballots are being counted um and I
think that that part of this legislation
is an extension of that it allows people
to look at ballots and you know give
some confidence that uh you know the
election was fair and
accurate representative
we
uh thank you um just with respect to the
effective date
and the availability of the two machines
approved by the ballot law commission do
you know or could you remind me when
those will be available and procurement
and uh purchasing Logistics aside when
would those be available to New
Hampshire so what I know at this point
in time is that both there were two
devices that were conditionally
approved uh a a device by a company
called voting Works which is a small
company but they use open- Source
software so the code is nonproprietary
and then the other device that was
approved was a device that's
manufactured by
Dominion um and marketed through the
local vendor that currently provides the
acuo they do a great job maintaining the
machines and their service is
good the uh voting
Works company came to us with their plan
to meet the conditional approval which
is go to a nationally certified
laboratory to make sure that certain
components of the machine will operate
and and that they're secure and it looks
like they are on track to have four or
five devices uh in four or five towns
available for the March toown
meeting uh and if that's successful then
there'll be more readily available uh
for the fall
elections Dominion threw us a bit of a
curveball uh because uh New Hampshire is
a very small and I mean a very small
Market to a company that size and at
this point it does not seem that they
are willing to take their product to an
as certified laboratory just to
satisfy the certification requirement
ments of little old New Hampshire what
they intend to do what they want to do
is take their whole Suite of products
many of which don't apply to New
Hampshire but you know have a national
market and submit them all at the same
time so I could not tell you at the
moment when uh the Dominion is going to
have when they're going to meet the the
uh you know the
certification conditional requirements
for the state it may not be until after
after the fall
elections voting works is doing it
though right voting works is still there
and and and and what was my favorite do
you
remember I don't I don't remember which
it was Voting Works representative weie
yeah so so ostensibly voting works is
available and for those towns and wards
that choose to use that
machine that would be
it would be feasible for this bill um
all changes aside um if it should be
approved um to use that you know as soon
as um scanning devices are available um
but
uh still waiting on those communities
that might prefer a Dominion machine or
something like that is that
approximately correct yes this bill
would apply to to the new digital scan
technology
okay res raer thank you thanks for
taking my question you mentioned that at
some point elections need to be final
what kind of a time period was would you
suggest for access to these images after
an
election three maybe three months four
months representative Brennan
thank
you um do you have an
estimated cost for the labor that would
be required of the Secretary of State's
office to
oversee individuals who are requesting
these digital images before you answer
that I accidentally turned your mic off
so if you turn a p on thank you that was
convenient I I I don't don't uh I
mentioned in when I first made my
remarks that parts of this bill needs
some significant refinement and and I
think it would be that refinement that
would determine what the actual cost
would end up
being okay thank you uh I have one final
question it's
philosophical um doesn't really pertain
too much to this bill so we had five
people vote in dixville Notch they all
voted for the same candidate we all know
how they voted did they have a secret
ballot six sorry six do they do they
have a secret
ballot philosophical
question I'll take that as rhetorical
yeah thank
you and that's right in case you're
wondering what goes through my brain
that's what goes through my brain does
make any noise we're in recess for two
minutes until we can start at
not
Rec
okay it's 11 o'clock we're going to come
out of recess uh I forgot to read in um
on hb1 1577 we had three signed in
online for support 30 opposed and three
neutral um so with that we'll close the
public hearing on House Bill 577 and we
will open up the public hearing on House
Bill 1705 relative to classifying
ballots as public information
representative mcarter you are
recognized to introduce the bill welcome
to election
law thank you chairman uh pardon me I've
gotten over a sinus infection this
weekend and it's still hanging on just a
little bit um Nicki mcarter
representative from Belmont representing
belnap uh District 8 and I submitted uh
HB 1705 on behalf of many constituents
reaching out to
me um just expressing their frustration
with the fact that ballots are um
excluded from 91a and worked with a
couple of different people and some
legislators on Crafting the language for
this bill uh which is what you have
before you right now
uh I just want to say a few things if
you are familiar with the case Miranda v
Arizona the Supreme Court stated where
rights are secured by the Constitution
there can be no Ru making or legislation
that would abrogate them so to exempt
ballots from a 91a statute I would
suspect sounds like the Supreme Court is
saying you can't do that that's
understanding of that they they should
be public records like everything else
um with the appropriate um means to
request uh that information as we all
know we just all voted on last Tuesday
uh ballots are Anonymous you don't know
who cast which ballot unless you are
from dicksville Notch um as we've just
discussed uh so I wouldn't think there
would be any privacy concerns with um
creating a method or means in which the
the ballots can be accessed through
public records requests uh for the
purpose of Citizen audits or um what
other other kind of queries that
somebody may be looking to do for
statistical research or what have you to
uh try to raise the confidence of the
voting populace that the results
published are the actual results that
were cast and I think we still have a
lot of work to do in that space getting
the public to
um to accept that our elections are safe
and secure and free and fair and that's
why I submitted this bill okay questions
from the
committee I will take question see none
I guess we'll oh never mind
representative qu is not going to let
you off the hook that easy thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative I
may not be able to answer I'll give it a
try I understand that it's long been my
policy if I don't know I say so and
that's a correct answer uh but thank you
for taking my question sure uh in
reviewing the bill uh it states that uh
ballots would no longer be exempt from a
a right to no
request uh that seems to imply to me
that that would be a requirement to
comply with all right to know request
from anybody any member of the public to
see ballots okay uh on page one line 6
through 8 directly following uh
section it uh specifies a procedure for
the Secretary of State to follow to have
viewing
opportunities but I I couldn't see there
where it says that's the exclusive
procedure for the public to view ballots
so I wonder if there's
a a contradiction there I mean it seems
to imply that it would still be possible
for anybody to request
ballots under a right to no
request I suppose there's room there to
to make some uh adjustments or some
amended language to tighten that up a
bit and I'd be happy to to to look at
that and do that as soon as possible
okay thank you welcome uh Mr chairman
can I have a followup uh you know what
just for you yes oh thank you Mr
chairman for that
courtesy uh
on lines 8 through
n it
uh the bill says uh
hang on a second every town in
Ward uh shall save scanned images of all
ballots cast in an election that seems
to imply a requirement that all towns
including those that do hand counting of
paper
ballots uh without a machine would then
have to scan ballots to comply with with
this uh portion of the the
bill I'm I'm thinking the intent here
would be
to facilitate ease in storage of this
information instead of having thousands
of boxes of ballots that someone's going
to have to Paw through now perhaps it's
easy it's as uh as simple as creating
electronic format uh to fulfill an
information request from a particular
Ward or uh
town and yeah I guess it would it would
mean that the towns that hand count
would need to have um high-speed
scanners to be able to generate those
types of images okay thank you for
answering my question and thank you
again Mr chairman representative wood
yeah thank you uh Mr chairman and thank
you for take my question the um actually
he asked the question I was going to ask
but I just was thinking that maybe you
did when you're doing the research do
you know why and when this exemption was
ma made uh to 91a I mean it it it seems
odd to me I have to look at the history
but do you know I do not know um I'm I'm
sorry I I read through this again this
morning and thought to myself self you
should know the answer to this question
because someone's going to ask that and
I did not look it up so I do not know
well I'll look it up for you when we get
the get the debate thank you thank you
represent
Burnham thank you Mr chairman um uh I'm
just trying to understand the process so
the calendar um to to view paper ballots
is set by the Secretary of State's
office current correct correct but the
viewing is taking place at the town or
city
location um I think that's the intent of
the bill so that someone doesn't have to
drive from say Co Brook to the Secretary
of State's office or state archives or
you know wherever wherever this ends up
being and I think that's that's a
logistical um thing that we as the
legislature should work to uh accomplish
okay um making public records accessible
to to the public they're their documents
part one article 8 says that um I think
it's our job as the legislature to try
to make that uh logistically feasible
and not um outlandishly either expensive
or inconvenient for the
public so perhaps yes okay followup
question just a second as a answer to
representative Wood's question our
wonderful as representative Aken
Arenberg pointed out to me our wonderful
committee researcher has prepared
there's a full memo on why ballots were
Exempted from
91a um including relevant case law um
and represent M if you'd like my copy of
it you're more than welcome to it uh
because I have it electronically I have
it electronically I'm
sure you follow from representative
barnham yes so um that would definitely
create a different um situation in the
towns and cities for their viewing my
understanding is that a public viewing
or or is it private viewing I just I'm
trying to understand it in in my town
like how that would work um if they're
don't if they're not scanning or don't
have access to scanning ballots at this
time I'd also think that that is again
something us as the legislature can work
to uh resolve that if a town uh hand
counts and they don't have the scanning
devices the high-speed scanners perhaps
there's one or two or several from the
Secretary of State office that get
dispatched to those communities so that
they can scan their ballots and the
towns that have access to them don't
need that resource I I'm not really
certain at this time how how the
logistics would work okay thank
you represent rter thank you thanks for
taking my question um this bill proposes
that the images are available within 48
hours after the close of an election I
think 1577 that we just reviewed said
after recounts so the 48 hours certainly
before any recounts um would you want to
I think there's room there to amend that
yes thank you further questions from the
Committee hearing none thank you so much
um secretary scalin you're up
next thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee I'm David scanland
Secretary of State I hear in opposition
to this bill and I'm not going to repeat
the testimony that that I gave earlier
um I think this falls in the same
category as uh trying to be as
transparent as possible between you know
the voter casting their secret ballot
and the finality to election I think
there's a strong desire to
see uh
uh efforts made whether it's through
audits or the ability to to a formal
ability to view ballots uh just to
instill that confidence that the
election was fair and accurate um th
this bill uh has some significant issues
with it I think they've already been
mentioned through questions of the
committee
um first uh I don't think that it is a
good idea that we give the public the
opportunity to handle uh the actual
paper ballots that is the official
record of the election and and that has
to be kept safe and secure and after the
election is over those ballots are
sealed and the only time that they are
opened up is if there's a recount that's
requested or if a court orders them
opened up because somebody brought a
strong case forward that you know we
need to take a closer look otherwise
they're sealed they're kept for 22
months for State uh or federal election
and then they can be
destroyed the history of the 91a
issue uh ballots have never been subject
to being opened up and reviewed after
the election is over and after the seals
have been placed on them except for a
recount or court
order it it became an issue uh in the
early
2000s when there were some academic
groups this is my recollection that were
asking if they could review the
ballots uh prior to their destruction
after the retention period was over for
holding them and the the uh the statute
uh making them subject not subject
exempt from 91a came about as a result
of that just to make sure that everybody
understood that you know that once the
election was over uh the ballots were
still to be kept private
um and the issue of making the images
of scan copies of the ballots available
in a format that is easily acceptable
accessible by the public within 48 Hours
of the election you know I suppose if
you threw enough money at it it could
happen but uh that would be a very
challenging uh thing to do so with that
I'd be happy to try and answer any
questions questions from the committee
seeing none thank you secretary scalin
Al
brandano y oh withdrawn easy enough um
and last up natch gra from the New
Hampshire Municipal
Association thank you Mr chair n gra for
the municipal Association I second
everything that secretary scanland has
already said today um we did our best in
the fiscal note uh to provide
information to LBA so that they could
calculate the approximate cost um we we
assumed that if we were to scan um
require that all ballots be scanned
within 48 hours that would require
highspeed scanners similar to the
scanner purchased by the secretary's
office
um in response to some legislation
passed uh for the election audits um I
believe the secretary had reported at
that time in a fiscal note that it was
about $40,000 for that scanner so when
we when we did the math we came up with
uh 9.3 6 million spread out over um all
cities and towns um so we do oppose this
legislation if I didn't say that in in
the first place um as the secretary said
we have a very robust system for how uh
how our elections are processed as you
were all very familiar we're very
confident in that system and we look
forward to working with the committee
and the secretary's office to continue
to improve that system and we don't
believe this is this legislation would
be necessary or assist us and in uh
receiving accurate results happy to take
any questions questions from the
committee represent
we
uh thank you Mr chair um thank you for
your testimony so the
9.36 million 40,000 scanners times
234 municipalities so it's the
assumption is that it cannot be shared
under any circumstances between
municipalities or you know from a
centralized unit coming from the
Secretary of State's office or something
like that that was our assumption given
the volume of of voting um given that
you know obviously there's some small
cities and towns but there's no
provision now for you know a town clerk
after they've sealed the ballots to
bring those to another municipality
unseal them scan them and then bring
them to where they need to go um that
would require additional legislation so
we assume that each municipality would
have to do this scanning on their
own follow yeah so I um I may be
remembering this number incorrectly but
I understand there are 135 communities
or so so forth right now that are
currently hand counting so the rest are
uh using the old machines and are doing
those and correct those machines will
eventually have to be replaced I'm
assuming that those communities will
probably not Veer toward Bo hand
counting having established the machine
usage already um with those as
assumptions do you think this 234
municipality number is still
correct um if there's only 135 hand
counting communities so there are 234
municipalities I don't anticipate that
changing um I don't know obviously it's
a local option so whether hand count or
not I don't know how that might adjust
um my understanding and I defer
completely to the Secretary of State
here is that
um the new machines that have that have
been going through the approval process
would not automatically save digital
copies of those and even if they did
you'd still have those ballots that
somebody under voted or over voted which
legislation I believe last year
clarified those are basically kicked out
from the machine put into the
the third pocket side pocket there so
you'd have a whole kind of little stack
of B ballots that wouldn't have gone
through the machine you have to somehow
account for those and account for those
votes um and obviously if we continue to
go with the intent of the voter if you
have something like an eraser Mark or
something like that um you know you have
to figure out how to get that scanned in
into the system so that you have a
accurate number of digital ballots and
you don't have kind of multiple piles of
ballots from one jurisdiction so I
assume what you would do is get kind of
a uh a high-speed scanner like the
secretary's office has that can digitize
all ballots regardless of how voters
marked them so that that could be
reviewed completely within that 48 hour
timeline thank you thank you further
questions seeing none thank you um there
are no one else signed up to speak in
person and my computer just shut so I
can't all right and so we had 36 people
signed in online in Support 32 signed in
online as opposed and two signed in
online as neutral with that I am closing
the public hearing on HB 1705 the
committee will stand in recess until
11:30 thank
you
okay it's officially
11:30 so we're going to reconvene the
house election law committee open the
public hearing on House Bill 1313 FN
local relative to access to the voter
checklist by candidates welcome
representative Cole to election law
everybody be gentle this his first time
here so representative you recognize to
introduce the Bill thank you Mr chairman
for the record representative Cole
Manchester House Bill
13113 relative to the access to the
voter checklist by
candidates so basically what this bill
is just asking the towns and the cities
to put it in a format that's sortable I
come from Manchester there a population
of 120,000 people we get our voter list
it's an alphabetical form and you can't
sorted so for instance when I want to go
out door knocking or politicking I want
to sort it by the street talk to
everybody on that street I can't do it
I'd have to bring my whole thing with me
and go by name so that's basically all
I'm asking to do it's pretty
straightforward I
think okay well you needed five you you
took five minutes you have anything else
you want to for the next four minutes 45
seconds or sure if any questions I don't
know I'm usually pretty straight into
the point so I mean that's are there
questions to representative Howard
yes thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh earlier today we
heard a similar Bill uh in which the
Secretary of State testified that uh
electronic copies sent by email may be
difficult to send and that the word
shall uh may be difficult language would
you be acceptable to changing that sh to
a May
sure thank you drives a hard bargain
representative
Burnham thank you Mr chair so my
understanding with this bill though this
is coming from the municipalities
correct correct only to the candidates
correct yep okay so then uh then that is
a possibility that it can be sent by
email I believe that's the way
Manchester collects the information now
is it's in a database everything you
take your driver's license and they just
scan you in now I mean that information
is already there I just want it to be
put in a format that's usable for us
right and I think everyone here can
agree that they probably wanted a format
that they can use when they're out doing
their
campaigning you know it's probably one
of the most bipartisan things I could
think of when I did this
so yet you put me on the bill which is a
huge mistake
so anyone else have any questions
represent oh uh representative Mirad
would like to give us his
knowledge I I would yeah I'm going
withhold I don't have much but I just a
quick question you said electronic copy
but you want a usable form do you want
it like an in a spread sheet would it
like would would an electronic PDF
file uh that wouldn't satisfy satisfy
you so it needs to this bill needs to
say more than sortable okay it says
sortable in the bill and that's exactly
what I'm kind of getting at as a
spreadsheet or some kind of sortable
file further questions are you happy
with your
co-sponsors I am very happy Ross gave me
some tips on it we uh cleaned it up a
little bit before we uh presented it to
you guys so representative weary uh yes
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony uh just a quick uh
clarification is this intended it says
in towns and cities so when the
Secretary of State testified earlier he
was talking about
Statewide um and the necessity or the
unlikelihood that such uh large list
could be sent by email but but for towns
and cities you're really talking about a
much smaller list then not a Statewide
120,000 people on a spreadsheet really
is not a big spreadsheet it's not not a
big deal so okay thank you very much
thank you for your question
representative
quae yes thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for taking my
question uh I note that on in the bill
itself it says the supervisors shall
furnace a physical copy to any person
requesting it but the title of the bill
says
access to voter checklist by
candidates it's just a I'm just curious
about that
difference thank
you it's a something we'll have to
resolve I imagine I guess so yeah lines
OSS makes the titles line seven and
eight yes because I I I have asked for
for my bills to be titled the best bill
ever and they refus to do it
so
but good catch the Deep State the Deep
state gets me again any other questions
from the
committee all right seeing none thank
you representative Cole representa Cole
are you over there in 304 today yes I am
can we have our room
back after we deal with the the Cannabis
legislation thank you uh one more uh
representative pelli I'm sorry is that
the right did I get the name right I'm
sorry toss it so fast yep representative
pelli you're up next see we can have fun
in election law they they said if they
said election law it's boring it's drve
why do you want to do no I said it's
fun hello hello again representative
Susan portelli Rockingham District 19
Hampton Falls and Kensington thank you
again for letting me testify here this
bill is similar to the one we heard
early this morning this morning but the
arguments are still very important
having access to this data is absolutely
critical to make sure sure that we
maintain our citizen legislature and be
able to access our first amendment by
getting out our message to our voters
and this simply States just send us the
data in some type of format where we can
sort it evaluate it and um use the data
very effectively in a very coste
effective way by eliminating this fee I
believe strongly it will encourage
enourage additional participation I
don't believe it's a burden at all to
send this data if absolutely
necessary the email could be sent in uh
you could break up the format and send
multiple emails this happens all the
time we have other committees that have
um a lot of data that's transmitted by
our town representatives for example our
planning board some of the documents are
huge and they just send it in multiple
emails and I don't believe that this
would be honorous to our town clerks and
I think it is a very specious argument
to say that people will be requesting
this data every day or every hour I have
not found that to be the case I think
that people that we want this data are
very serious about making their message
heard and I believe this is a very
bipartisan effort and it will benefit
benit
everyone that is interested in democracy
and making sure they have the ability to
reach their voters so I respectfully ask
to pass this bill o OTP 20
20 uh questions from the committee
representative Bay thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question uh to
your comment about no one will ask this
data every day I don't believe so so uh
would you be open for saying that uh
limiting the request let's say every
election cycle or candidate can request
make this
request perhaps we can let the town
clerk determine if there is someone that
is abusing the request perhaps we can
put some type of language in there but I
really believe that access to this data
is very important and I'm sure that our
town clerks can monitor that to see if
there is anyone that is abusing it and
um perhaps you know referring them to
the Secretary of
State followup um do you find any reason
for a candidate to uh request this data
more than once every election
cycle and and again I believe that
access to the data is the important
issue and not the frequency which I do
believe will probably be every election
cycle but if there are some updates or
there's a specific reason I would really
hate to limit that in but I would hate
to limit that by law and I believe
people are very reasonable and they will
understand that this is a benefit to
them and that they won't abuse this
privilege but it is public data and
we're just
the bill is just saying make it in a
format that will comport with where we
are today and how we communicate today
and I wish that we still had the Town
Square and you we made great speeches
and everyone came to the public common
but unfortunately we're in the
electronic age and we really need to
make sure that we're accommodating that
thank you representative BR thank you
and thank you for taking my question are
you aware of
instances where community members
individuals are requesting information
from
municipalities and abusing that
information such like the checklist or
you know 91a
requests I worked with my town clerk I'm
gonna pause real fast can can you define
what abuse
means um there are instances throughout
New Hampshire where people are
submitting voluminous requests uh that
is
overburdening the municipalities and the
town clerks and town employees uh so
that might be one form of abuse and then
another form of abuse might be
requesting the voter checklist and using
that voter checklist to Target specific
individuals based on the information
found on that checklist um Target them
for harassment and such it is something
that is happening and so that is the
basis for my question are you aware that
these things are happening in
municipalities and affecting communities
and individuals who are subject to this
type of abuse of public records well the
right to no law is something totally
separate so it has nothing to do with
this request and I don't believe that
there is a lot of documented cases
because the information is public you
could walk into your town hall and look
at the information so it is totally
public this will not change that in any
way it's just making it available in a
sortable format so my town clerk in
correspondence with other Town clerks in
the area have absolutely not had any
instances of abuse or uh undue requests
as a matter of fact we want to encourage
public participation and make sure that
we're making it easier for small
communities large
communities to
have their um public officials be able
to communicate a message or their budget
committees or their Schoolboard
committees and increasing information is
something that we're very proud of here
in the state of New Hampshire
further questions from the
committee okay hearing none thank you um
there's no one else signed up to speak
um online there were 41 in support one
opposed and zero were neutral so 41 to
one it's pretty good where are the
neutrals I I don't know they didn't show
up um that's the only that's the last
bill we have on the docket before our
lunch break uh so we'll come back I'm
going to close this public hearing let
me say that formally I'm closing the
public hearing on HP 1313 uh we will Rec
convene at 1:00 sharp on HB
1704 um and um before we go I am going
to schedule us for next Tuesday um
basically we are going to meet every
Tuesday going forward um my goal is to
try to get through all of our bills
before the end of February um so there's
going to be some kind of longer days in
there um we I am going to consult with
um representative Lane um on the
possibility of us voting uh session on
Thursday is supposed to be short so I'm
going to consult with representative
Lane to see if there's consensus on any
of the bills that we've heard today that
we can dispense with on Thursday um I I
have the rightest chair to do that
arbitrarily on my own um but I'm not
going to do that I'm going to consult
with the ranking member um so please be
aware of that it's only going to be for
things that we have consensus on um so
just as a FYI Tuesdays long days uh they
will start being executive sessions on
the back half of it um and Please be
aware of that On th th you might hear
the hey election laws meeting um
announcement so representative where do
you have a question yes is it is it
possible to foro the last Tuesday in
February when school vacation yes that's
school vacation so I want to be done by
then because we don't have session for
that so no we're going to be hauling um
we're going to be hauling I like
Holland's a good thing so you know on a
personal level my game plan is to
dispense with election law and then I'm
going to focus on the childcare
committee um because we have a lot of
good work we're doing over there too so
so um any other questions comments
concerns all right would you think about
Wednesday next week instead of Tuesday
uh Wednesday is when I'm doing childcare
so
no um all right I'll see you guys after
lunch
e
okay
1:00 definitely was here I'm going to
open up reopen the house election law
committee and open up the public hearing
for 1704 FN relative to the
reconciliation of ballots act um is I
don't have it oh here we go Prime
sponsor
mcarter represent mcarter
here you are up you are the prime
sponsor to introduce the
Bill thank you Mr
chair I'm Nicki mcarter from Belmont
represent belnap uh County District 8
and I submitted this bill another one um
on behalf of a group of constituents to
try to shore up some of the um some of
the doubts uh with our election system
in part two article 32 the founding
generation prescribed the mandatory
terms of contract in this constitutional
voting Provisions the terms expressly
call for humans to sort and count the
ballots human eyewitnesses are necessary
component of the New Hampshire
Constitution part two article 32 because
only human eyewitnesses can be called on
to a witness stand placed under penalty
of perjury and compelled to
testify of what they witnessed during
the sorting and Counting of ballots any
machine which replaces humans in the
sort and count is an automatic
interruption in the human eyewitness
chain of custody prescribed for in the
sort and count this bill will codify and
detail the parameters for an acceptable
sort and count method of the New
Hampshire election ballots I have the um
the the original as submitted um bill in
front of you we have an amended version
um that was drafted by the original
author I was not the original author but
that man is here today and we have uh an
amended version that we'd like to
provide to you when it's her turn to
speak and we will submit that to OSS if
that's uh o okay to do that copies of it
now yes let's just distribute it now I
think I don't but when he gets up to
speak he has it okay all right so I'll
defer to Mark uh Rosetti as the author
of the bill I submitted on his behalf I
merely acted as the conduit for the
information that's totally fine we'll
direct our questions
to Mark there it
is good thank you that's all set I I do
that all the time it's my favorite thing
to introduce the bill and say no
questions aios
no Mr edti do you have your proposed
amendment I do if you want to distribute
it to the committee before we start it's
it's a courtesy um we tend to act in
good faith here so if this is what you I
totally get we don't always make the
deadline I got my own thing to
distribute too here
so there are two pages underneath of
each
one and I think I counted 13 people
here I just gave you five of
those
there
and've gotten that
far
one thank you for your patience
folks
hello folks thanks for hearing me
today
um I decided to write this bill because
a number of people before you start uh
give me your name and your town Mark
Rosetti West
Hopkinton
and I find
that by examining the Constitution and
looking at our
rsas um the reason why I wrote this was
New Hampshire
RSA the 6 5640 was passed in
1979 and it was created to utilize
voting machines on a temporary
basis to me that is overriding our
Constitution and our
constitution part two article 32 talks
about voting so I'm going to read
something quickly here and then I'm
going to explain a couple of things
about the bill and I'll be
done the the New Hampshire state
constitution is the law of the land to
be
enforced
unless amended written in 1783 and
rewarded in the 1792 part two article 32
specifies how and when votes are to be
counted
and it has not been amended it has not
been changed so to amend the an article
of the Constitution required by a vote
consent to the people I article 32
clearly states that votes be governed by
a moderator who shall in the presence of
selectman whose Duty it shall be to
attend an open meeting receive the votes
of all of the inhabitants of such towns
and WS pres and shell in said meetings
in the president of the said selectman
and the town or city CER clerk in said
meetings sort and count said votes I
don't see
electronic vote counting device anywhere
in article
32 so we
have machines in this
state that are not constitutional for us
to use to vote with I can prove it 10
different ways from
China so these machines are
dangerous and I decided to write this
bill and what happened was I was
contacted about it 4 days before I
started writing about it and I worked
around the clock to write it because we
had to pass it into by a certain date
and when it got passed in it was my
first draft and that first draft came
back from the lob quite marked up and
doesn't look anything like the bill that
I created so you folks have in hand
now my second and final
draft and um so the negatives negative
connotations that were found in this
bill that
came
back from
from the
L I've got that copy here
someplace no I don't I need
to yeah if you look at methodology on
the second to last page it speaks about
the costs so on and so forth I've made
all of those with my second
draft I've made all of those with my
second draft very irrelevant the costs
have mostly gone
away and let's
see yes methodology so there are a list
of negatives there mandating one poll in
place for every 5,000 El eligible voters
is gone requiring all ballots to be
stored in a 24 continuous 24-hour
continuously electronically surveyed
secured that's basically turned into at
the town where they collect the votes in
the new draft they're held and then
brought up as usual by a selectman but
they will need to be archived at the
State uh the state archives that's where
the ballots are held now but the only
difference will be surveillance at the
state archives in a in a different way
of order but all these different things
here are basically alleviated that you
see in theth mythology
um I've I've basically taken wipe those
out with my
second uh second
draft so there you have it that's that's
all I can say
um
the NS and bolts of it are there for you
to read if you have any questions I'd be
pleased to
answer questions from the committee
represent Hammer thank you for taking my
question
have you ever worked an
election I have not okay I have not but
I've studied them deeply I've been up to
the state house here probably more than
most of the Reps do in one turn since
1992 and I've watched closely okay thank
you f questions from the
committee here representative Brennan
thank you um thank you for taking my
question I appreciate the work that you
have done on both
drafts um and I understand your
testimony is that you
have taken all of the negatives out of
the first
one uh to make the second one one of
them being the suitable polling place
for every 5,000 eligible voters right
your second draft says limit all polling
locations to 5,000 lawful voters and
that's on the bottom of page four um
page I understand that that
isall that's supposed to be gone I'm
very
sorry I put this all together as fast as
I could believe and we couldn't pass it
in okay further questions from the
committee okay hearing none thank you
for your testimony
uh next up is it's two
lobbyists oh no it's not it's one
lobbyist um natches
gray thank you very much folks I'm sorry
actually Mr Gray I'm I missed secretary
scalin
card it's a so in case anybody knows the
order I always go by it's elected
officials the Secretary of skate the
general public and then lobbyist the
lobbyist you guys get paid to be your so
get to go
last
thank you Mr chairman uh members of the
committee I'm David scanland Secretary
of State here in opposition to House
Bill
1704 uh frankly when I started to read
this bill I I really couldn't get beyond
the end of the first page where the Bill
calls for placing serial numbers on
every ballot along with a perforated uh
receipt that goes along with that and if
you were here this morning uh in
testimony that I gave on an earlier Bill
uh one of the most fundamental things
about conducting El an election is that
every voter should be guaranteed that
their ballot is going to be secret and
private and anytime you put a
distinguishing number on a ballot that
can be tied to the voter that is a
serious problem and so I would oppose
this bill just on that basis um I
mentioned that that we we had an issue
with vote buying and intimidation
schemes prior to
1890 um because there were ways for
individuals to find out how people voted
and this bill basically goes back to
that uh that time frame and creates that
opportunity especially where the bill
says that you can take the perforated
receipt go to the town clerk or the
Secretary of State whoever's housing
those ballots for a period of 5 years
and actually obtain a copy of that
ballot that you could then show to
somebody that might be offering n money
for uh purchasing a vote so uh just on
that basis alone I would urge the
committee to kill this bill and I'd be
happy to answer any questions questions
K representative B thank you Mr chairman
on the constitutionality issue could you
please relate to that like it counting
how doesn't say anything how it's
counted correct yes and I I think that
uh the prior testimony is certainly an
opinion on what the Constitution says uh
I believe that the courts have taken
this issue up in in past cases and from
my perspective the Constitution says
that the vote shall be sorted counted in
public which is what happens it's just
that there's a ballot counting device
that's counting those ballots instead of
teams of uh volunteers at the polling
place thank you further questions
representative Brenan thank you are you
aware that there have been numerous
studies done uh testing done that shows
that
tabulators uh ballot counting devices
more accurately tally the votes than
hand counting or another way that there
are more errors in hand counting than
there are with the use of tabulators or
ballot counting
devices I'm aware of studies uh to that
effect and they confirm that but you
know I don't want to minimize the
concern that's out there sometimes the
machines fail and and and uh we saw that
happen in Windam uh in New Hampshire
when you know a crease through an oval
was improperly counting ballots and so
when things like that happen it it
certainly
um causes some concern and the way we
deal with that is we have a robust way
to make sure that uh we can verify the
results whether it's an audit process or
you know a formal type of review of
ballots but then when that process is
done there needs to be finality to the
election followup please
yes are you satisfied with the two new
new ballot counting
devices that there would be minimal
errors and with our process of auditing
via hand counting uh
in uh in the way that you that is
prescribed in law in the way that you
typically follow are you satisfied with
the two new Bal counting devices and our
established processes for auditing
elections that there would be no need to
mandate and Counting um as this bill
does well we went through a very
rigorous process to uh so that the
battle lock commission could approve a
couple of devices one of those is an
open source
software code that is nonproprietary so
anybody can take a look at that I think
that instills confidence but I think we
still need to have the opportunity for
uh hand recounts where we look at every
single ballot and that those ballots can
be challenged as part of that process
and I think that we need to come up with
a good audit system that will instill
confidence in the results and you know
we know that the legislature tried to
address that that last time and um
didn't work out that well so hopefully
we can do a better job this time thank
you further questions seeing none thank
you next up is rousan
Chester
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members um my name is russan
Chester I live in Bedford New Hampshire
um I've been involved with election
Integrity for many many years in New
Hampshire um with concerns going as far
back as when I lived in hooks at New
Hampshire uh so that's more than 15
years ago um I did not become involved
until the Dominion
machines became um common place in New
Hampshire uh but the bottom line is is
that there is a huge issue of trust and
lack of
transparency at my town every single
election there are anomalies there are
issues uh in 2020 we ran out of ballots
so we took a bunch of copies there was
no chain of command there was no
everybody was just doing their own thing
and that's not okay so that's a little
bit where the audit responsibility comes
in the other issue is the machines that
we use currently sir can you turn the
flash off on your
camera thank you I was like I don't have
a flash
on um the the other um issue is that is
that the current machines that we use
are what they call completed
closed uh we have no transparency
whatsoever I was a programmer back in
the 70s I don't know if you folks most
of you folks probably don't remember uh
don't go back that far but one of our
sayings used to say garbage in garbage
out and these programmers all LHS is is
a middleman they are not proprietary
they do not own these machines they do
not make these machines they do do not
manufacture these all they do is do the
program that is sent to them on those
chips and they update it but no one here
at the State of New Hampshire is allowed
to see what that program says there is
absolutely no checks and balances so the
fact that we have two systems one is LHS
which is a completely closed and the
other one that's an open source now the
nice thing about the open source is that
anybody it's very
transparent and transparency is so
important right now in our elections in
every aspect of Our Lives because we the
people do not
trust the people that are in our
government positions we don't trust our
election officials in some cases
sometimes we do but I don't know if you
folks remember Bedford from 20120 where
1,500 missing uh Mi uncounted mail-in
ballots were withheld now that was not a
machine issue that was a people issue
but the bottom line is head the attorney
who was the assistant an attorney who
was an assistant moderator had not
advocated to keep it a secret we would
have found out about those 1500 ballots
and those 1500 mailin absentee ballots
may not have been
disenfranchised it is time for complete
transparency and I hear about robust
Audits and when we're going to have a
problem well I was just at the most
recent election in Bedford and I watched
a town counselor bring up four
batches of ballots that they
found to be hand
counted now how does that happen there
is absolutely no transparency and this
bill allows the bottom line is things
are so broken can we even talk about
well we'll just use the machines and
we'll keep going it is unconstitution
the Constitution is not an opinion the
Constitution is clear the Constitution
says every ballot will be handled will
be hand counted now if you folks want to
use a tabulating machine and then as a
second do a hand count well then you're
meeting the the requirement of the
Constitution but to say that the
constitution is an
opinion is
egregious in my
opinion I have years and years of
watching things go not quite right the
election before this one in
2022 I submitted
23 issues that were brought before the
Secretary of State and or the Attorney
General's
office because I sat there and watched
it it's happening it's happening
throughout our state and there's already
a lot of towns that do hand counts when
the machines went down this past
election even more had to do hand counts
maybe it's time to get back to basics
it's not going to take much longer
especially with the poll books right now
which is another disaster because it
switched over over 4 00 people in our
town got switched from their
party
somehow electronics are only as good as
the
programmers Electronics can
always always be hacked and yes not all
people are righteous not all people have
ethics and morals but I would rather
trust my town clerk and my elected
officials than dominan voting machines
and LHS
and I'll stop
there questions from the
committee seeing none thank you oh I'm
sorry representative Brennan got get
that hand up
high thank you are you aware
of a nearly $800 million
settlement of from
defamation from Fox Corporation Fox News
against uh or other way around Dominion
against Fox News the claims that they
made about the
Dominion tabulating machines um that Fox
News needed to pay out almost $800
million for lies that were told about
Dominion machines I am aware of that as
I am also aware of the um uh research
that was done by Harry hursty prior to
the Windam audit that showed how easily
was to hack the Dominion machines thank
you resident
hamr thank you for taking my question
have you ever worked in election yes I
have
various in Bedford yes got ask for the
follow yeah we just had a big chairs
meeting about that so I'm supposed to be
I'm supposed to be meanor about that I'm
sorry follow up
followup in Bedford yes okay thank you
all right yeah so you guys know you they
had a big meeting of like hey if
somebody wants to do a followup they're
supposed to ask and it's like okay so
just doing what the boss says um any
other questions all right hearing none
thank
you um M Markus Mr you refiled um I'm
going to indulge you on this um the
hearing is not a debate so if you have
additional testimony to give that's fine
um but it is not the hearing for the
general public is not a debate so we
can't start up a back and forth so are
you agreeable to that yes okay
the uh ballots that the Secretary of
State asked about the perforations on or
didn't bring up the preparations so the
ballots would be
printed like this on three pieces of
paper and it would be perforated on the
top and there would be a number on the
top on that perforation that the person
tears off and carries with them and it
would match the number number on the
ballot it does not have their name on it
or anything like that so if there's a
recount on the ballots everybody can
take that perforated Tab and come back
and see proof of their ballot that's
very important
secondly um paper ballots are the gold
standard of uh of voting and machines
are pretty dangerous as I said before um
the issues with these devices are only
discovered through hand counts if
they're allowed hand counts challenging
the machine count may may only be
requested by candidates and I don't like
that it should be able be bu the
citizens that they're
requested and and the um the issues with
these ballots used for devices noted in
Windom in the Windom audit report
included but not limited to different
paper thicknesses s folds C
folds um and many other things that
caused overboots where the device could
not read and fails fails to do the fails
fails
to uh properly show the the town these
machines um are dangerous and we have a
company named LS LHS Associates based in
chum New Hampshire and this supposed to
be safeguarding the voter's integrity
and sovereignty um
this this company has no government
oversight nor any Audits and they put
all the machines that we have in New
Hampshire into New Hampshire so I'm I'm
also sad to disagree with you Mr
secretary but um the article 32 part two
of The
Constitution is pretty strongly written
and to see it overwritten and then
see uh these committees that think that
the constitution is just an
opinion uh or people when they say that
that's very bothersome to me if we're
not following that Constitution we're
really in trouble thank you very much
for your
time representative
wooden thank you Mr chair um I wanted to
ask for clarification in the question
that okay that's fine okay you so the
way you described
this
the way you describe this the
perforation does not stay with the
ballot that's correct the ballots would
be printed in such a way you remember
the old time cards when we were younger
we used to put them in the clock okay it
would be a time card like that but it
would be three separate
pieces and they're printed and they're
put together and then the top is
perforated mhm the voter tears that
perforation off folds it and tears it
and puts that in the pocket and then the
vote goes in so no names are written on
that okay and uh my question is are you
aware of any other state doing that I
believe Idaho is doing something like
that and has brought something in but I
I didn't have a lot of time to to do
research on this thank you thank you Mr
chair okay uh representative uh
weary uh since you brought the
Constitution are you aware of any
current cases before for uh New
Hampshire supreme court regarding the
constitutionality of the voting process
yes I'm aware of a few cases but I
haven't watched them closely okay
representative Brennan thank you um are
you do you
know um the costs of hand counting um
one of the things you had suggested was
that any citizen should be able to
request a a recount rather than just the
candidate um and if I'm understanding
your testimony correctly you're wanting
um any individual to be able to request
a hand
count do you know the costs associated
with hand counting and if such a law
were to be passed that any citizen could
request a hand count what that cost
would be to the
taxpayers it would probably be very
limited because if two or three people
in each town or County suddenly mourn in
the can come they they'd be finding a
lot of dirt and I would see on the
opposite end of that kind of behavior
people would not be wanting to play with
fire and I've also found that hand
counting this is common sense is far
less expensive than these machines that
we've got to purchase to maintain them
and to keep them
up I think I I and I also will state
this strongly the sovereignty of each
individual in this country because it's
a republic is highly important so when
we go off that gold
standard of each individual having a
ballot we're losing doesn't matter the
the accuracy of Machinery is not there
and will never be as fast as in mind in
things like like this situation never so
I I strongly believe in each individual
casting their own
ballot and the reason why is because my
freedom the freedom of your children my
children my
grandchildren is all county is all it's
it's all balancing on that right now and
they're getting away with murder with
the machines I just would hate to see
that in our state
thank you okay thank you um next up
we'll do um natches
gray I'm Nate just I'm just going to
butcher it every time man I I I don't
know where we're at at this point that's
that's totally fine Mr chair n Grays
with the municipal Association if if it
helps you n like nature gray like the
color um I we also oppose this
legislation I will
I Echo everything the secretary of state
says I have not had the opportunity to
review any amendment that was passed out
um the legislative budget uh assistant
was kind enough to put um a long list of
things that may cost municipalities
money into uh the fiscal note um I won't
read those to you but that is basically
the uh the basis for a number of
concerns that we have in addition to
overriding concerns like the secrecy of
the ballot and the importance of that
I'm happy to answer any questions the
committee may have questions from the
committee okay representative Brennan do
you know the costs associated with hand
counting
ballots I do not know off the top of my
head but I believe there was a bill last
year or the prior session that had a
fiscal note attached to it that would
give you that information thank you any
further questions seeing none thank Youk
um no other speakers are sign up to
speak in person there were 37 people
signed up online in Support 32 opposed
zero were neutral with that I'll be
closing the public hearing on 7 HB 1704
and opening the public hearing on
HB 1699 allowing caucus identification
on ballots um representative gearhard I
saw you do I have a pink card for me
representative
gearhard is he gone is he here I saw
him representative Penza you want to
stand I saw represented Penza
she um well anyways to get the public
hearing going oh there he is sorry about
that
Jason Gart Franklin Northfield Mar 25
oh um go ahead and introduce the bill I
apologize this bill would allow caucus
identification on
ballots if a caucus had at least five
members in the house they would be able
to
approve members of their caucus to be
identified as such on ballots
and this would also apply to the Senate
and executive councel as
well the the reason for this is I think
voters need more information deserve
more information about who they're
electing versus just the parties certain
states allow Fusion voting which be
allow the multiple listing of parties so
you could run as a Republican and
libertarian or whatever it may be this
is a little bit different and I don't
think people necessarily want to be in
two parties I think having multiple
caucus um designations allow information
to be given to the voters but also to
allow candidates to transcend so-called
party lines but on issues so if it was a
veterans caucus they could it could be a
republican running with that as well as
a Democrat and there's no conflict um I
think it's pretty self-explanatory I'm
willing to take questions to answer any
questions and what where I was trying to
go with this if there's confusion
any questions representative
Brennan thank you raise higher that time
um I see in the bill that it mentions on
line seven five members of the house
shall be registered in a caucus with the
house clerk for inclusion on such list
and I see in the methodology here that a
brief description of each caucus 140
characters or fewer will accompany the
ballot and I I guess what I'm wondering
is is it not possible
that a group of five close colleagues
could create a
caucus
and you know that caucus could be you
know registered on the ballot with those
names and couldn't every
five State reps create their own caucus
and wouldn't that result in a ballot
that is multiple pages long with
descriptions of different friend groups
of five that we call a caucus
is that not possible or I mean I suppose
that would be possible but I think kind
of defeats the purpose of what they'd be
trying to accomplish in a way point
being is the more members of a caucus
that existed the more significance it
would have to the
voters at as a whole do you know what
I'm trying to get at in sense I I
understand you're saying it could be a
political statement the you know
whatever um I if that did occur to me
afterwards and I was starting to really
think about it I think there could be
limitations if the threshold could be
increased I suppose I just didn't want
it to be something so excessive that you
couldn't in a sense have some of the not
Fringe elements but things that aren't
necessarily everybody wants to be part
of kind of groups something that
actually represents something that some
voters May care about but still
significant enough that you're not going
to get dozens and dozens of people
signing up
for followup followup please um is it
not the responsibility of the candidate
to provide their voters with enough
information about themselves during the
uh election or primary
process so that that voter can make an
informed decision based on what the
candidate has provided them rather than
the ballot isn't it the candidates
responsibility yes but I think many
people say that they received too much
political propaganda mail during
campaign time I okay I don't know me as
a blue collar kind of guy I don't the
people that I'm around most of them
don't vote and they'll tell you because
I don't know who I'm voting for and I I
actually respect that position way
better than just going you
know or people vote the party line which
even though I'm part of a party I don't
really believe in that policy I think
you should look at the candidates on
their own merits and I think this helps
this helps at least give a little bit
more information especially with the
description that would be on the ballot
itself I okay would it be a little bit
more paper uh perhaps what the voter
this is important I mean we're voting on
people that are supposedly representing
our interests let's find out who they if
they have to pick three caucuses it now
forces the candidate to say okay these
are the three topics or and they don't
have to join a caucus so be it but it at
least kind of clarifies what this
candidate is focused on versus just the
the blue and the red or whatever you
want to choose to go with representative
B thank you Mr chairman thank you take
question five people well let's all get
together and make a bunch of dummy
caucuses just to get votes I mean
nothing to prove that I'm for something
or against something just that I put a
name up say you know so anything just so
I know those people like that whether or
not I believe in that or not I don't
care I would just want the vote so how
what good is
it um I would think that it would have
to do with the caucus has a standing if
they actually do what they believe so
it'd be the same thing with Consumer
Reports or other a um private entities
that rate products if they lie they lose
credibility they go out of business do
you know I think your your it's your
credibility that's at stake so the
members that would be part of that
caucus if they're fing just to be
useless or they're endorsing people that
aren't fulfilling their their
so-called
no representative
Mirad um I I sort of like your idea um I
have a little bit of a concern about how
the ballot would look have you thought
about that
yes well I'll let the co-sponsor take
that question any further questions uh
representative Arenberg anenberg ex me
I'm just going I'm just butching
everybody's names today it's all
everybody's up on the table uh thank you
representative uh I just have a question
about um what is it line six here house
caucus members shall submit a list of
approved caucus members um
MH so what if I wanted to be a member of
a caucus and I was not an approved
member is there an appeals process or
and I guess where I'm going with this do
you see a scenario by which not being an
approved caucus member if I wanted to be
a caucus member could create a problem
well I think that's the whole idea of a
caucus you control your membership keep
the quality up
so
sure so you so you would believe that
not every member of the house would be
eligible to be a member of a caucus I
think that's how it currently
is okay I mean maybe I'm wrong but one
more followup so would would this then
be creating different classes of
candidates on the ballot then because if
you can exclude a member from being um
you know if you can disclude membership
of that
caucus um aren't aren't isn't isn't that
caucus then weighing in on the
legitimacy of the candidate in in
regards to caucus
membership I would say that a caucus is
a private entity the private entity can
choose its
members am I missing the rephrase it I'm
confused I'm not really picking up what
you're trying to say am iow yeah yeah
sure yeah okay it's Tuesday why not so
if if the the caucus members are
submitting a list of approved caucus
members yes and I wanted to be a member
of the caucus and and you're saying no
are then now the the caucus itself is
taking the the place then of say the the
Secretary of State um in what will
appear on the ballot we I don't believe
we do that in any other case because
even like the the major parties and
things like that there's a I guess we
say we're we're adding something
different to to the ballot that would be
an ident a unique identifier to the to
the candidate and their membership in
something but then we're we're saying
that there's another group that would
then be saying yes or no right and like
even even the party itself doesn't do
that right so are are aren't we then
creating a different class of
candidate I would yes I guess so but for
the purpose of providing an identifier
that you are part of this group and it's
yes so okay short answer be yes thank
you okay further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um I'm
going to recess this bill very quickly
so we're recessing 1699 um Mr Healey I
miss your pink card for 1704 would you
still like to testify on 1704 uh yeah
okay so I'm going to reopen the public
hearing on House Bill 1704 for the
purpose of law Mr Healey to testify
thank you so so you guys know we are on
relative to the reconciliation of ballot
acts previous bill so uh Dan Hy uh
nashwa City Clerk and current president
of the New Hampshire City and town
clerks
Association and I just want to uh
register with um the uh election law our
strong opposition to this bill uh for
numerous uh
reasons um you know currently with the
tabulators and larger communities we're
finishing some elections 2 3 in the
morning if we had to hand count all
ballots uh cast in those elections we
would be there well until the next day
uh we're already working uh 24hour days
some of us um I think other laws need to
be changed to allow hand counting over a
course of a few days it's not something
that could then continue on Election
night in in most larger communities with
the tabulators again um I reported my
results around 1:30 in the morning um
and delivered them to our drop off
location around 2:30 in the
morning um all ballots being serial
numbered um prevents um provides more
more issues uh for us it says to that a
voter can come in and retrieve their
ballot the you know following the
election the ballots have to be sealed
uh with signatures from the moderator
the clerk Selectmen they have the red
security tape what would be the
procedure then for opening those ballots
those boxes up uh and retrieving those
ballots because now they're not secure
uh 24 24 hours a day
surveillance um I don't think is
realistic uh most communities to install
a camera just pointed at the vaults uh
who's monitoring that camera do we go in
every day and watch the last you know
overnight what happened is it motion
censored how are we monitoring that
camera if there's a 24-hour uh camera on
those
ballots um just overall just looking at
this bill there's there's just a ton of
things in here that prevent that provide
challenges for uh clerks they provide
challenges it it uh for Secretary of
State it
just
I I'm not sure what this bill's trying
to to accomplish um it just it seems to
be
adding a lot of things that um that are
going to be very hard if not impossible
for us to to implement so i' be open to
any questions any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you and my
apologies Mr Healey I was not I just got
put over here um I arrived into the room
late um so I was trying to get my card
in but but thank you for allowing me uh
the opportunity just to get our opinion
on the record of course with that I'm
going to reclose HB 1704 and reopen HB
1699 um representative penzo was up next
but I believe she has left the room uh
secretary scanland you are up HB
1699 thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee I'm David scanland
Secretary of State and just like to talk
to you a little bit about
uh the ballots themselves in that the
ballot is designed to treat every
candidate on the ballot equally and not
give any candidate you know any more
visual influence uh than any other
candidate on the ballot for example when
a candidate lists their name on the
ballot we do not allow terms like doctor
Professor uh PhD coach uh because those
are all designations that kind of
elevate uh a person potentially in the
eyes of the
voter and then when we come to uh adding
additional things on the ballot um yeah
I just like to say that designing a
ballot is a very complex process
especially in New Hampshire where we
have many many candidates and many many
offices on the ballot and there are
rotations of those columns and the names
of candidates on the ballot that are
required in
statute so there are literally hundreds
of different versions of ballots in any
given election and they all have to be
meticulously proofed to make sure that
you know there is accurate as they can
be and even with that you know sometimes
we find one or two misspelled names so
to add additional designations like
caucuses that um just makes that job a
lot more
complicated and then when you come
specifically to state representative in
addition to the rotations that I just
mentioned the the names of state
representatives are staggered in their
party columns to try and make it appear
like uh those candidates are not running
against specifically running against
another candidate in the other party and
so I can see um
that field on the ballot growing pretty
dramatically as a part of that process
so my recommendation would be that there
are other ways that candidates can
advertise what groups they affiliate or
belong to but it should not happen on
the election ballot I'd be happy to
answer any questions represent bum thank
you m chairman than question and would
it also mean extra work for Secretary of
State's office to verify the caucuses
well I I hadn't thought of that but you
I suppose we would want to make sure
that they're registered with the house
clerk further questions hearing none
thank you um that was the last person
signed up to speak in person
online guess
not no she she
left
Miss Chester you're you're fine to come
up thank
you I'm so sorry um thank you committee
chair thank you committee members um the
only thing I want to say about this that
I like is that again it gives us a level
of transparency and accountability that
we're missing in our elections uh we
currently in our town um during a local
election we had an indiv individual that
go was going
around um representing
himself as uh as very different than
what his what his belief system was and
there are a lot of people that trust and
don't verify unfortunately I used to
think that New Hampshire was the New
Hampshire voters were uh pretty educated
when it came to Casting their votes
since becoming in more and more involved
and actually um running for office I've
learned that that's not always the case
so that's the reason why I like this
bill um specifically for local elections
where it's not um where party
designation is not identified having a
caucus option uh for people would be
very beneficial similar to like when
we're running for State Rep we get we
get um approved by nhla uh because we
fill out uh we fill out um a
uh
uh uh survey thank you very much uh so
we fill out surveys the bottom line is
is any of these Co caucuses that were
were to exist if that's how we become
members of a caucus and if they if
they're
not honest if they're if the part if the
members of that caucus are not walking
the walk then it's going to be apparent
the first first election cycle and they
won't get reelected and I think that's
why it's important at least for local
elections I think it's very helpful for
our voters um especially with the with
regards to State reps Senators executive
counsels Etc um the bottom line is is
the one with the most money often gets
the most votes and unfortunately it
shouldn't be that way but it is because
mainstream media
controls so much of what our vote is is
telling to the people of New
Hampshire that's it I'll take any
questions questions from the committee
okay hearing none thank you all right
now we will close um 1699
uh online there were 32 signed up in
support 16 opposed one neutral uh the
committee will stand in recess until 2:
p.m. in which we will hear H uh hb1 1426
FM look like we've recovered have
you
on
okay it's 2 o' I'm going to open up the
house house election law committee
public hearing on hb1 1426 in
consultation with the designated ranking
member today we do have many people
signed up to speak for this so I will be
limiting public testimony per individual
uh with five minutes I did consult with
the ranking member on that to reach
consent um with that representative
Mirad you are recognized thank you Mr
chair thank you that's
enough he's been waiting for two years
to waiting two years to G him down
but it's to do that today would be
particularly unfair because I'm not
speaking simply for myself but for the
estimable representative Lane who is the
Prime sponsor of this bill and who's
asked me to speak on her behalf this
morning this bill would establish an
independent redistricting commission to
draw District boundaries for the State
House the state senate State executive
Council County Commissioners and the
congressional districts in the year 2031
1 the excellent thing is that sitting
here s years away we do not know which
party will be in the majority in the
legislature in
2031 and so this isn't a bill that's
meant to penalize uh e either side by
the way there'll be a kind of midterm
presidential election I think in 2028 so
my guess is that whichever party does
not control the US Presidency will
probably benefit in 2030 and control the
legislature hard to predict which party
that'll be right now it's impossible
actually so the basic idea here to
create a commission nine people three
Democrats three Republicans three
Independents and have that commission
with the staff create Maps hold public
meetings deliberate about those maps and
recommend a set of maps to the
legislature to make a recommendation
seven people on that nine member
commission would have to agree so
imagine just by chance that the
Republicans and the independent stick
together maybe their Republican leaning
Independence those six people wouldn't
be enough to make a recommendation they
need at least one Democrat to join them
put differently you need at least one
from each of these three groups
Democrats Independents and Republicans
to get to seven and and um and and the
legislature has the power to accept
those maps that recommendation or design
its own legislature is constitutionally
empowered to to draw its own District
Maps so it's an advisory commission to
the legislature and the basic underlying
intuition is that maps that all the
relevant parties Dems Independence
Republicans age on are going to be more
fair Maps the maps that just one party
agrees on and that the other party or
parties vigorously opposed that's the
basic idea the basic idea is that more
fair maps are better than than maps that
some large chunk of the population views
as unfair and uh and and uh my students
young people today I mean I they they
they really are extraordinarily
skeptical about the formal institutions
of constitutional democracy it makes me
worry about the future and they think
it's you know corrupt whether they're on
the right whether on the most of them
are kind of just in the center they're
not super ideological on the left they
they think this and they think it's not
good to have partisans draw maps to
favor their own party that just strikes
them as unfair and this is an effort to
to get the parties to come together to
uh see if they can make a recommendation
that everybody agrees to and that that's
the plan that's the bill um and it makes
a lot of intuitive sense to me even
though I'm not actually the prime
sponsor happy to take
questions representative
bone thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question my problem is the
same as in the past is what's an
independent nobody's independent
everybody's got a bias one way or
another so that's been over the years
the commissions that we've tried to done
that's always been defeated has always
been that what's an independent so how
can you find a real
independent yeah I'm with you the well
the the word independent comes into this
bill in two different ways one is that
the The Advisory commission has nine
people three registered Republicans
three registered Democrats three
registered Independents by the way
they're chosen from retired a group of
four retired uh state judges but I agree
with you so those registered
Independents I I think just speaking as
a political scientist which I played
during the day um it's true that most
most Independents lean toward one party
to the other pretty reliably um and so
they're kind of closet Republicans
closet Democrats so let's just imagine
that the three Independents are all
Republican leaning and you've got three
Republicans and three Republican leaning
Independents they ain't got six people
who are kind of more sympathetic to the
Republican party than the Democratic
party as a Democrat I could say well
that's unfair but for the committee to
make a recommendation at least one of
these three Democrats to get to seven
one of the three Dems on this nine
person committee is also going to have
to join the other six and and I think
that's the check against the possibility
that The Independents won't you know
will lean one way the other as a whole
group um we could also amend the bill so
that it's all you know it's five Dems
and five Republican or you know five I
guess you can't do five and four so I
like the
333 but I think that's the key thing
then the other idea of independent is
that it's making an independent
recommendation and there I think all we
mean is that it's a recommendation that
the that both sides agree on it's not
really independent it's more
bipartisan further questions BR can you
speak to um the adoption of
redistricting maps on the page five
starting in line 10 and discuss
what the implication is of this
commission the maps that they
submit if the legislature must accept
the maps or what
happens with the suggested maps from
this
commission the recommend the the
commission would make a recommendation
to the legislature the authority of the
recommendation would be based on the
deliberation that the commission put in
and the fact that all the relevant
groups agree such that they could get to
seven people a majority of seven out of
nine people but the legislature doesn't
have to accept the maps the
legislature um may find that there are
problems with them and legislature is
constitutionally empowered to decide for
itself whether to accept this
recommendation or um or create an
alternate uh
plan further questions from the
committee you still have uh 45 minutes
so he wrote 90 minutes on his card uh
thank you representative
Mirad um okay next up here let me see
here let's go with with Phil Hatcher Mr
Hatcher and as they say Mr Hatcher you
are on the
clock thank you I'm Bill Hatcher I'm
from Dober see my representative Bay
here today
um so I was a member of the mapathon
citizens mapping project so I'm very
well aware of the kind of Technical and
legal acies of drawing the maps um and I
believe it's would be wise to delegate a
group to do the task um because the
legislature as you guys well know is
overwhelmed every year with when the
order of a thousand bills to
do um and also frankly you're under um
political pressure when you're drawing
Maps which I think is probably not best
for the state in terms of coming up with
districts that are best
represent the citizens of the
state so that's my first point second
point is I think we can all agree the
process that we're using is not working
very well unless you're a fan of the
judicial system drawing Maps if we go
back to
2000 the governor and the legislature
disagreed on the house and the Senate
Maps so so Supreme Court had to get
involved get a technical person to
actually draw the
maps that didn't go so well if you
remember um that person decided not to
use
fluer
districts we ended up with big
districts many towns lost their
dedicated
Representatives this led to an amendment
to the Constitution in
2006 to provide try to better provide
dedicated representation to towns of
adequate
size that init is under litigation now
in statford County Superior
Court in
2010 again the governor and the
legislature disagreed on the
maps however the legislature had a super
majority at the time and they overrode
the governor's
veto so you might CL you know might
realize that okay we were saved that
time by super majority in A legislature
there was still extensive litigation it
was all eventually dismissed however um
20120 we had one party in control of
all of both the governorship and
legislature but
still the governor and the legislature
couldn't agree on the Congressional Maps
so what
happened Judicial System drew the
Congressional
Maps
okay
so where are we headed is this is this
what is
this good is the legislature and act
actuality actually drawing the maps in
many
cases um
no um looking ahead to 2030 you
know what's going to be the situation
and we're a purple state right it seems
unlikely that one party is going to
control all
three important entities here um it
seems even more unlik
ly that a party will have a super
majority in the
legislature so what's likely to happen
in 2030 if we continue doing what we've
been
doing the courts are going to draw the
maps is that what we
want I don't think so so I would ask you
to consider this bill and and I know
there's there's a constitutional
amendment coming forward also you I ask
you to
consider that we're not actually doing
what we think we're doing okay and to
finish up I just want to add a
historical note I have a copy of the um
pole tax receipt that my grandfather
received in
1908 in mlon County
Texas and now you know we look back in
those times and we
think it's embarrassing right it's
embarrassing that we used a p tech
mechanism to keep people from
voting um I think 100 years from now
people are going to look back on this
era and they're going to be embarrassed
that we didn't fix this problem with
Jerry mandering we know it happens both
parties do
it
right citizens through polling don't
like
it we have you know 21 states have done
a commission or something like
it I would strongly recommend and I hope
you would seriously consider adding New
Hampshire to that list of
states thank
you nailed it 12 seconds left
um any questions from the committee okay
hearing none thank you Mr
Hatcher all right Mr Andrews it's good
to see you again brother how are
you hi uh my name is David Andrews I
live in conquer now um I worked as a
data analyst for the redistricting data
Hub I was the lead mapper for the
mapathon um project and I am the uh
expert witness in the Dober lawsuit
challenging the New Hampshire house Maps
um the current process of redistricting
in this state and in this country is a
crack in the found Foundation of our
democracy
um we have not done a very good job job
in creating fair and Equitable districts
in our state
um all of the maps besides the
Congressional map are Jerry mannered to
favor one
party in this voters from both parties
are
disenfranchised we create safe districts
for both parties and thus we move our
elections from the general election to
the primaries this creates
officials who are further to the
extremes of each party than to the
center which is um in my opinion what
the state of New Hampshire is more um
like the this creates less bipartisan
agreement um it creates more
animosity and it is not helping our
democracy to be its best self um
so the idea of an independent
redistricting commission is something
that I
wholeheartedly um want and
support this bill however is not ideal
in some ways um I believe that the uh
that a constitutional amendment is
required in order to you know guarantee
our rights as voters to fair and
Equitable um
maps and also within this bill I see
some flaws
um one of which is the idea of um
compactness being a uh ideal of this
commission it's not necessarily
something that
is needed or can be agreed upon in
there's a lot of different ways in order
to calculate compactness not everyone
agrees on what they are and they're not
always good yes you can sometimes look
at a map and say that might be Jerry
mandard because it looks very funky but
there's also other reasons why a map may
look funky um and may not have super
compact districts for instance um let's
say you wanted to use school districts
as a community of Interest so you wanted
to keep School District together our
school districts are not compact they
are some sometimes funky shaped so then
you get funky shaped districts out of it
and not compact districts um so in that
regard I
would I would uh recommend that you you
know maybe amend to kind of get rid of
the compactness element of this bill uh
again
uh I'm not a huge fan of the the 333 um
because it's again it doesn't seem as
bipartisan as it could be i' like the
model of um 555 and thus having three
members of
each having to be able to vote on it so
you'd have you know You' need nine
people to vote on a map to get it passed
three Republicans three Democrats three
Independents and therefore you get the
majority of each party rather than you
know just one you may have you know a
moderate Republican who sides with all
of the Democrats and all The
Independents you know want that you want
a majority of each uh party to agree
upon these Maps
um and then um no offense but I think
that the legislature has shown itself to
uh not be trustworthy enough to be able
to be a pro part of this process and
therefore I think it needs to be
independent of the legislature and the
legislature should not be able to over
deride a map uh of a independent
redistri commission um we've seen in a
number of states that have similar bills
to this um New York
Ohio uh Florida um where the legislature
has ignored the wills of Voters who want
Fair redistricting and has thrown out
maps and gone with their own Jerry
manard maps and it hasn't really fixed
the problem I fear that this uh bill is
actually kind of just moving the bucket
rather than fixing the leak and so I
would um although I am in support of
this bill because I think it's a step in
the right direction I think that it
needs to be a a step further and a
constitutional amendment needs to be
brought forth I know it is but um and
yeah I'm happy to take any questions and
you too nailed your time 14 seconds left
um questions from the committee
representative
Brennan thank you
just to make sure I'm understanding your
testimony you are in support of this
bill because it takes a small step
forward toward an end goal of an
independent redistricting Commission in
your mind that would eliminate the
legislature from the process but this
would be a step in the right direction
is that am I understanding your
testimony correctly yes yes correct um
you know our the mapathon project tried
to emulate what this would this
commission would actually do um we put
forth Fair Maps um we brought them
before you know members of the public
who commented on them
we then submitted them to the
legislature and were um
ignored
so resident
we thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um what were the
distinguishing attributes between
between what was proposed by your group
and the other
redistrict uh Maps was there an
attribute or some quality that that made
them uh set apart and unique from the
others um yes so uh depending on the
level of uh the legislative map for
instance um you know for the New
Hampshire house Maps we tried to strive
to create as many um single member uh
districts as possible or not single me
but um single town or Ward districts as
possible in order to comply with the
2006 Amendment saying that eligible
towns or Wards should have their own
districts um so we were able to create a
map that had 41 towns that didn't get
their own districts rather than the 55
towns that didn't in the current house
Maps um in other Maps we strive to
commet to keep communities of Interest
together um like uh we used uh school
districts for one example uh we also try
we also kind of ignored the um incumbent
advantage that they used when creating
the the New Hampshire Senate Maps where
they said explicitly that they were
creating these and they weren't moving
um incumbents out of their districts
unless they had already moved or
whatever was the case um with District 2
or whatever but
yeah let's um keep questions relative to
the bill itself the bill is about
forming an independent redistricting
commission um I certainly would love to
re to relitigate redistricting um so I'm
not going to indulge myself in that I'm
going to ask the committee also does not
indulge in that we are focused on the
bill at hand representative
quae thank you Mr chairman having read
the bill it appears to me that it
attempts to make the redist
redistricting process independent of the
political
process and if that's the
case how does this independent
commission how is it accountable to the
voters so that it there's a better
chance that it will reflect the will of
the
people yeah so thank you um
the I'm not sure I didn't write this
bill I don't know um I
my idea is that when the I don't know
the exact process of how these people
who would be appointed to the commission
would be there but I would I I would
think that you know if you wanted to
include the legislature at all it would
be in appointing those people to those
so you it's a you know almost like a
representative democracy like we have
the we vote on the um you know the
legislators who then can appoint people
to the commission that's my idea of how
uh a independent commissioner would work
and therefore they would be
accountable further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you Mr
Andrew it is good to see you even though
we disagree a lot it is good to see
you okay uh next up Olivia zinc open
democracy you have some testimony right
I do have written testimony you want to
go ahead and distribute it now sure so
it's not making the ways while you're
speaking and people are looking down and
looking up and trying to do multiple
things I have lots of
paper um for the uh good afternoon um my
name is Olivia zinc I'm a voter in
Franklin and the executive director for
open democracy a nonpartisan nonprofit
uh with 36,000 voters across New
Hampshire and we're submitting testimony
and support of an independent
redistricting commission um I just want
to give some math from the last election
um in
2022 50% of Voters cast ballots for
Democratic senators but they only got 10
out of 14 Democratic senators
50.1 12% of Voters cast ballots for a
democratic executive counselors but
there was only one out of four um
executive counselor uh existed and 50%
of the State House was cast for
Democrats um and there's only a three
seat margin so at least for house
members there's much more evenness than
there are for the Senate and executive
Council Maps um and I would say this if
the Republican party got more votes and
got less seats it's important that we
understand that uh voters should be
picking their
politicians that politicians should not
be picking voters in drawing the map
this is why this independent
redistricting commission is is a good
idea um this committee has in the past
made bipartisan recommendations um that
have gone on a couple of times I hope
that your committee can can work
together on the legislation um in order
to do this I do want to say that this is
constitutional um as it is advisory and
still allows for the legislation um to
the vote um to be held um by the
legislative body um and to
representative qua qu's question I think
redistrict and drawing Maps is a
political conversation in many times and
I think what it shouldn't be about is po
is power and who which political party
can get the most Advantage should be
about voters and instill instilling
trust and confidence in the process um
also Linda Bundy is unable to be here
from antrum and has written testimony
and Bob Perry um is unable to be here
and has written testimony and I have
submitted both of those as
well okay questions from will you be
taking questions you I know you normally
do miss sink um are there questions from
the committee representative
Bo thank you Mr chairman thank taking
the question you're given the numbers
here of percentages but the problem with
those percentages is for example in
house districts very you aware they have
to be kept in the
county they cannot cross the county
lines so that could don't you think that
could be a problem with total
numbers I I think that if you wanted to
change the way on how County delegations
are selected and and make district lines
that don't cross you know or have a few
um you that is the the rules the the you
can set rules that allow that and I
think that you should in the next seven
years think about what are the the
criteria that goes into dry lines and if
you want to change that rule that might
be one to consider only someone had
submitted a bill to get rid of County
delegation yeah that was me
follow up yeah but the problem with that
is state
representatives you know are also the
county representative so they have to be
in the county right but I think like
belnap County for example could have had
19 18 and a half state representatives
and I think that if you were able to
give belnap county 19 state
representatives you could have better
drawn that map um and maybe one person
one state member had to be members of
two County Commissioners cuz they
overlapped um but you look at towns like
Tilton and Northfield Tilton's in belnap
county northfield's in marrat County
they share a fire district they share a
school district they share police fire
so many different things and I think
that um our you know New Hampshire's
unique in that way and I think looking
at what are the different pieces that go
into drawing a maps are
important for the questions
representative
Brennan thank you previously there had
been a question about accountability and
I'm wondering if you might opine on the
legislature having
the right to approve or disapprove of
this advisory committee's or advisory
commission's uh suggested Maps does that
allow for accountability by giving the
legislature that power the legislator
still has the final approval of the maps
and I think that um the voters can hold
the legislators who who who vote up for
the commission's recommendation or not
for the commission's recommendation
accountable and I think um the public
debate I mean when we think about what
the public debate was a decade prior um
the maps were drawn kind of behind
closed doors so there was a lot more
transparency in the process this time
but I think New Hampshire couldn't do
better forur the questions seeing none
thank you Miss sinks good to see you
it's good to be back all right we've got
6034 dist two of you guys you guys want
to go together from 603
forward we'll allow it we've got Liz Liz
Wester and Matt mushan musin um mushan
mushan that's the I got the all right
well anyways there's those two you can
start then I'll
cool good afternoon chairman Barry
members of the committee thank you so
much uh my name's Matt mushan I'm a
voter in Claremont and I serve as the
advocacy and engagement director for 603
forward we're a nonpartisan nonprofit
organization dedicated to uh educating
empowering and uh mobilizing Young Folks
across our state and today I'm here to
testify in support of House Bill 1426
which would establish an advisory
redistricting commission um you know
with the census being conducted every
decade it's imperative that our
legislative in Congressional Maps
accurately reflect our population in
demographics and as more young people uh
come to the granite state to live work
raise their families it's really
critical that we ensure our
representation is both fair and
Equitable and you know at the end of the
day that's what the redistricting
process is all about um during the 2021
redistricting process 603 forward
mobilized hundreds of young gr Staters
to take action for fair maps in a
transparent process and they did so
because they believe voters should pick
their politicians not the other way
around um and unfortunately while the
house redistricting committee held
hearings in each County uh the map
drawing was still done secretly uh
behind closed doors and out of the
public eye um this advisory independent
registering commission created by the
bipartisan House Bill 1426 Implement
some key safeguards against partisan
gerrymandering by being transparent
requiring public input and not allowing
maps to favor one party over another um
um it's been said that house bill 1426
is a constitutional uniquely New
Hampshire solution to creating Fair Maps
uh because voters should dictate our
future maps and it's important to note
that um this commission is advisory and
does not force A legislature to adopt a
map that it's produced simply provides
the legislature and the people of New
Hampshire the opportunity to see and
support what a fair map option would be
um and then just in closing without
safeguards in place voters who end up
and jander districts would continue to
find themselves disenfranchised for a
decade and Beyond um so we ask you
please vote uh in support of house B
1426 and be part of a solution to ensure
that we have a system designed to make
sure Granite State voices are heard in
the red dis searching process so thank
you for your time
consideration um hi I'm Liz Wester I'm
one of the co-founders of 603 forward um
and just to add a few points to what
Matt said um this bill um would limit
who can serve on the commission um so
there's been previous legislation filed
um that did not Place limits on who
could serve on the commission so um this
bill would make sure that anyone who was
affiliated with or worked for a
candidate or a political party would not
be able to serve so really this
commission would be made up of New
Hampshire voters who are representing
their communities not another interest
um those Commissioners would also be
picked by a nonpartisan body made up of
retired judges um it would take a lot of
public and Community input which is
really really important in crafting maps
that would be fair for the state um and
puts in some strong um wording around
making sure that the maps would not
favor one party over another at the end
of the day creating an advisory
commission is about restoring trust in
our elections um which I believe
everyone in this room wants our voters
to have um and would set up a path for a
fair redistricting process in New
Hampshire all right you taking questions
sure excellent representative bone hey
Mr chairman than taking the question
since this is just advisory like I said
and
the legislature can just completely
ignore it then don't you think that
would give the governor more reason to
veto it and then again have the
Judiciary pick the district I would hope
that very much like needing to have
seven members of the commission pass a
map that it would um encourage
compromise within the branches of
government that need to vote on these
Maps um to make sure that the maps are
as Fair as possible um it
is redistricting is hard and there is no
perfect process um but believe this is a
step in the right
direction further questions
representative Brennan thank you thank
you for taking my question um I'm
looking at this bill and and I'm
realizing that this commission would be
required to act in public meetings which
says to me that there would be more
transparency in this process I'm
wondering
if the meetings that this commission
would have in
public um might that
generate significant public support for
the outcome of the commission's maps
that they suggest to the
legislature and then wouldn't the
legislature then feel that public
pressure to adopt the independent
redistricting commission's Maps thus
again providing for
accountability in this process I think
so yeah more people participating in the
process for democracy the better thank
you further questions seeing none thank
you guys so much thanks for indulging me
doing the uh the TW for there thank
you um next up Miss tantarelli Miss
tantarelli happy New Year happy New Year
sir my name is Liz tinelli I'm a voter
in Newbury Undeclared by party and I'm
president of the League of Women Voters
of New
Hampshire we strongly support this
measure as one step forward I've been
cleaning out papers at my house before I
moved to the old age home I figure I
better get a head start on it this going
to take a while uh and I've discovered
testimony that I wrote and delivered in
favor of independent redistricting
commissions dating back to
2011 so I've been at this a while um the
state League adopted a position in 20
2004 I think so let me talk about why we
want to support this we know that it is
not constitutional for an independent
commission to actually make the maps and
have them enforced as conditions stand
now but an advisory commission certainly
increases the transparency as
representative Brennan mentioned and the
citizen
involvement and in
21 we had good participation of citizens
the legislature that held the hearings
around the state uh held one in each
County and got plenty of participation
from people talking about communities of
interest and so
on but I wanted to talk about one
specific moment in history here in New
Hampshire and that was in
2019 and I realized some of you were not
on this uh Committee in in
2019 when we had a very similar Bill to
this an advisory independent
redistricting commission which passed
the house 2018 to
[Music]
123 that means there was strong
bipartisan support for this independent
commission the Senate tweaked the bill
where it passed on a Voice vote again
Strong by partisan
support and until the very last minute
we thought that the governor would sign
it he did not he vetoed it and uh nobody
wanted to challenge that
apparently in
2019 this committee the house and the
Senate recognize the value of an
independent advisory commission it's a
tool to get the best redistricting map
possible with the involvement of
citizens
taking the partisan uh you know what's
in it for me and my district uh aspect
out of it to some
extent uh with non- legislators
designing these maps in a fair and
transparent process so I hope that you
will support hb1 1426 and I'd be glad to
take any questions questions from the
committee seeing none thank you it's
good to see you again m t thank you and
good to see you all Mr O'Brien with
America
votes thank you uh Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Michael O'Brien
I uh work at pry strategies and
representing America votes here today I
think most of what I said was going to
say has already been said um and so I
just want to quickly just remind again
the committee um that this is an
advisory commission and so Falls uh well
within uh the bounds the Constitution
because the legislature does make the
final say in these and that our
democracy is strongest when people
believe in um believe in it and in this
case we know uh through polling and
other uh other means that uh there is
question and I would argue justifiably
so about folks drawing uh Maps when they
have self-interest and this helps to
remove at least part of that
self-interest it does still obviously
lie in the hands of the legislature um
to make sure that um because they have
final approval but again uh creating a
public process where a map is created
brought forward and is seen uh hopefully
would provide enough pressure with you
know the kind of agreement that this Law
requires um that these Maps would
continue moving forward and would become
law as opposed to um Maps may be
approved by one part another and just to
stress again we're talking this is not
to redraw maps that are already drawn
right this is not to look and say we
want to do this in two years or anything
like that but for 2031 in a year when we
do not know um what control looks like
and so this provides an apple this this
is a good time to do this because both
parties um don't have an idea of what
2031 will look like um and so there is
no Advantage uh given at this point uh
happy to answer any questions uh that
you all may have um that's all I got
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you thank you last up um Mr Clemen
totz from the ACLU Henry did how do I
get your name was I
close the only you're the only one who
didn't fall victim to my Butchery
no um for the record my name is Henry
Clem toich uh on behalf of the ACLU of
New Hampshire I submitted online
testimony which I hope I haven't really
used before I hope you all got um and I
don't want to repeat what others have
said so just say please add ACLU of New
Hampshire to the list of many
organizations and people who've come out
to testify in support of this bill and
who do support an independent
redistricting
commission it's always a dance to try to
figure out what the best way to ensure
public
accountability um to those drawing the
maps is uh well weighing against that
the possible self-interest that folks
have I think that this proposal draws uh
an excellent balance
um in an improvement from previous
versions it uses a panel of retired
judges to help select the Commissioners
to hopefully you know pull out the most
civically minded Among Us um I think
it's a great uh a great first step and I
hope the committee will support it thank
you very much and I'm happy to take
questions questions from the
committee seeing none I imagine this is
a uh thank you so much Henry want to
grab one more card here which I know was
coming in hot Lou oh Miss Spencer I I
didn't think we were going to get away
with it
today um thank you so much Miss Spencer
thank you for taking my testimony Mr
chair Louise fencer from the Kent Street
Coalition we're an all volunteer
Grassroots um advocacy group and um our
the this is one of our primary
priorities is redistricting and it goes
to the point of accountability because
if we have heavily gerrymandered
districts we're not able to hold our
electeds accountable um when people are
in safe districts so in the interest of
really having a robust democracy and
Civic engagement it really
depends on people feeling that they can
give their input to their
legisl legislators and get feedback so I
just really wanted to stress that point
and say that we're fully on board also
and we have members across the across
the state and across the
street I live on Ken street but um yeah
I hope that during this you know we're
we're years away from redistricting this
is a great time for us to come together
and come up with something that we all
can believe in and and sign on to thanks
so much okay will you taking questions
uh yes I okay are there any questions
there are no questions to take okay
thank you so much um Oops I did not pull
up the bill
online um this is 1426 oh I did pull it
up online Okay um so there's no one else
signed up to speak um there was 336 366
people signed in in support 33 opposed
01 neutral um with that I will close the
public hearing on 1426 there's no other
business on the committee's calendar
today for the committee's awareness I am
going to schedule the bills for next
week literally right now um so if no
more than nine of you want to hang
around and make a pitch for why your
bill should or should not be heard next
week you're more than welcome to do it
but I'm literally going to sit here and
do it uh with that it was great seeing
everybody and I'll see you all again on
Thursday thank you we are we are
adjourned